[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what's going on you guys can you hear me
fine
i'm extremely tired you will never know
it can you hear me
fine
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
all right and i believe we are live
welcome everybody to episode 176 of the
iron lords podcast
as those of you who have been with us
for a long time know and have been
indoctrinated
anytime you hear my voice at the top of
the show you know something has gone
left
you definitely know something has gone
wrong so once again
as as he's prone to do since lord
cognito has abandoned us
you know since he's since he's been
elevated to another status he can't
be seen with the peons or whatnot he has
uh
forced me to host the show
as he gets a much needed r of course of
course but he he will be joining us in
progress so
what's up everybody welcome to episode
176
this is fantastic we have some special
guests in the realm today two gentlemen
who are not strangers to the realm
at all so let me introduce them first we
have
um the creator and host
of the ps trophy room podcast mr bad bit
himself playstation nation stand up
what's going on man
it's uh it's been it's been a it's been
a couple of days guys
it started off great and
why the pause man there's a long pause
there yeah you had to compose yourself
first
you know jim tap dancing ryan needs a
feeling
that's all i need to say what is going
on man what you've been doing this week
besides playstation stuff but what have
you been playing
oh man i've been playing the new call of
duty uh
the alpha so far so far so good like
i don't know if it measures up to modern
warfare because i really like last
year's but the sound
like the sound in this game is is
something special so that's pretty much
what i've been playing uh other than
just like
you know head down working on the trophy
room stuff but
yeah it's it's been a busy week man oh
batman are you basically saying that you
don't need to have that spatial
3d audio to take advantage of great
sound
and it's on the playstation 4 too real
talk
real talk when i'm playing it like this
is not for me like to stay in my
playstation
right now but i'm i'm already like i
can't wait to see what this is gonna or
hear what this is gonna like sound like
like on playstation 5 and on the series
x like
the well you're able to secure uh
whatchamacallit uh um
uh pre-order luckily
fantastic we'll get into that that'll be
a section to the podcast unto itself
right
so let me just tell you i the only thing
i managed to secure was that headset
so
let's leave it there so i got a mans man
you you can get it for that eight nine
and nine
i'll tell you about my situation a
little while so of course
next up another person who's no stranger
to the round table
our brother panelists on the brat
podcast and scumcast and according to uh
to rand outdoor and 10 million other
podcasts
at me forte what's going on brother yeah
man what's going on man it's
it's great it's great to be here with
you guys man as always i always get a
chance to just watch it from work or at
home now i get
here with you guys again so absolutely
man there's a lot of smoke about to
happen today i'm gonna try to mediate a
lot of this as much as possible but i
don't know
i don't know man sometimes you gotta
sometimes you gotta let the dogs eat
and i think that's what's gonna happen
today that might be the kid yeah cognito
cognita was like look man
let's get forte in there to get some
balance because you know
they're gonna be loose today
gotta let people gotta let the
playstation
all right so what you've been playing
man i i know you you recently recovered
from uh
from uh what's going on right now
yeah yeah definitely so i've been
playing the call of duty beta
the alpha 2 and dog it's pretty cool uh
i'm with a couple other people though i
kind of got bored halfway through so i'm
hoping that there's a little bit more
substance to it once we get the full
game it might have something to do with
the fact that war zone is pretty much
the best way to play call of duty at
this point now so
right unless they have another way to
spruce that up with the new game
i kind of just feel like this is just
going to be more of the same when the
new game comes out
but outside of that man it's just been
working
telling customers to stop being mad
which we'll get into later on
and uh that's pretty much been my life
oh and then playing destiny because of
double drops
in the nightfall so i've been doing that
pretty much the entire week with luke
and tass
what what what is that game you talked
about at the end i never heard of that
game
oh you never heard of it guess what
guess what on september 22nd
what is that thing called king that you
know phil spencer gave us
that's going to give us something on
september 22nd what service is that
what's it called game pass yes yes
september 22nd
oh dios need to this point
when the x comes out because i just want
to see it on there that's it then
it's gonna look and run fantastic i
believe that's
that's great customer service though to
be honest with you
to to be able to get the dlc for free if
you have game pass
sure um anybody that hasn't played
destiny in a while
all that stuff and it costs people
because i paid for it
so um 200 plus dollars for me yes from
you to get it free man
that's kind of crazy that is kind of
crazy like i'll be i'll be at least
trying it out november
when it when the the new expansion comes
out what november 10th right
like that's that's what i'll be trying
out i have i haven't played it since
shout out to that day uh bad bit no we
got a new
member of the room in the chat lord
spiderman three
five six welcome to the realm for your
brothers
up for your brothers fantastic thank you
so much for the support
right so let's introduce to three of the
four horsemen of gaming that are here
today
we have of course the co-host of the
iron lord podcast the young wolf of the
ilp lord addict
what's going on brother
addict in uniform baby
we got 79 likes get them likes up guys
if we get them to over 300
let's attic has to take off the t-shirt
first of all right now
well first of all i'm a little
disappointed because that outfit ain't
complete he ain't got no straws in his
mouth
i thought i thought honestly he would
wear the um the wife beater
um you know with the hole in the nipple
i thought that was gonna happen but um
hey man i'm happy that yeah guys they're
saying they added you're you're muted
no he's not muted he's fine i hear him
fine what happened
do you have oh he i don't did you unmute
yourself sir no
yeah i'm here now i'm here now okay okay
okay i i muted myself to make sure the
podcast sounded right on my phone and i
did not immediately
but yeah yeah i'm here you guys i
apologize if i'm out of my word i got
these whacks somebody put it down
as soon as
oh we got two more dislikes hello people
i don't know
he said of course we have the incredible
hunk of the ilp
beloved lord king david otw what's going
on brother
oh man you better call me prophet
baby what's going on people you know
what it is today
are you all feared
[Music]
sunday is here i want all
your tears and a bucket in your knees in
a box
bring them to me bring them to me know
the funny thing is over the course of
the whole week i was watching like a
bunch of playstation podcast and
it was like this it's like this
consistent message like
lord i can't believe that king david was
right
this is the thing about king right king
i i gotta give it to ken cause king will
sometimes make
predictions that seems so outlandish but
he doesn't care because
what happens is when one hits you're
done for life
for life you're done for life he will
never let you live that one down and
rightfully so because a lot of them are
shots in the dark like nah that's never
going to happen
but it really isn't if you look at the
tea leaves
it's true and you can tell exactly
what's happening and what's going on if
i mean most of the time it'd be common
sense some dudes just be like no
i refuse to listen to your brain
i'm like okay but you're gonna be messed
up later
and it happens there's a reason why i
call him jim dan's moves ryan it's the
absolute reason
mr fred astaire was in rare form this
week
and of course you know you got lord
sovereign here the
fair who lives for the selfish single
people can't even ask me what i'm
playing
oh my god you're like your worst house
in the building
somebody get him out of it what what
were you playing okay so
um shout out the game pass you know i'm
captain pass
so i found out recently this week they
had um stranger things added there
um black desert came back again and left
and came back um
so i said uh let me try out this hot
shot racing
and hot shot racing reminds me of uh
virtua racing from back in the days
mixed with a little bit of daytona
and i was like oh this is kind of it's
kind of fun and you know i have the
power sliding like ridge racer
so it felt fun my son loved it i i think
it's fantastic
so i downloaded the stranger things like
i said but i went back to the resident
evil remember i was playing it
on um playstation vr
and i was like hell no i can't be doing
this right here this right here make you
throw up
um so and i mean throw up from fear
um from you know being sick with the
headset
so i started playing it again i'm not
gonna lie
capcom was onto something when they made
that game
as creepy and as down to earth as they
did it
because as soon as i got back in that
stupid house again
and had to move the the pot cover again
and saw the roaches on my arm again it
gave me that
that pit in my gut yeah oh my god i'm
back in this claustrophobic scary ass
house
all over again so um i can't wait to
finish this game up because i never
finished it up and i'm glad it's here
so i can play it on you know my ex with
the high fidelity and all that other
stuff
and get to that eight because that eight
is like an extension of this and keeping
with that same creepiness
i'm down for it man so i was really um
pleased with what i saw with the
playstation uh uh gameplay uh
uh thing the show
with that part you know so i can you
know get that resident evil because you
know they show some nice stuff about it
but that's all i've been playing
okay so where are you in the game oh i'm
very early on remember i stopped playing
uh the playstation one and the
playstation one i was pretty far
right so you know but i stopped playing
there so now i'm starting
all over again oh and by the way i
finished uh the avengers marvel avengers
which to me plays
just like a beautiful movie script it it
was
very well done uh all the characters had
good progression
uh it's a real grounded take
on their world and
it can be easily implemented into the
mcu
so i won't be surprised if a lot of
those uh
story parts that you saw will be used
in the mcu for how mutants came about
because they at that point in time they
weren't using the word
mutant they was using inhumans because
remember uh this game was in the
development when fox wasn't part of
disney
so they couldn't use the word mutant and
when you see it there's a lot of
surprise moment it was
one moment that i actually stood up with
the controller and i was like oh my god
so it was a fantastic uh you know take i
i really loved the game uh i think the
story is fantastic they have to work on
the little things on it right but other
than that
it was a really good game it's worth the
money i
understand let me ask you but now you're
saying that you finished it
yes the problem with the game is what's
going to be
next forward do you see do you see
yourself enticed enough to want to go
back and play more once new stuff comes
out
oh yes you feel like you you feel like
there's still more for you to do
well when they start if they're smart
about it and they want to do it like
destiny
and you know like when uh dlc drops for
it
it has more to the story because it's
some stuff
it's just like a marvel movie stick
around and watch the end credits
because it's things that happen and
you're like
what the hell was that and it leaves you
like oh my god
and it's a cliffhanger so
it's gonna you're gonna come back to it
i mean you know what i
really felt sad about automatically when
i finished the game
the the people on xbox side
who won't get a chance to play
spider-man
because the the spider-man part
of it if it's a large part of the story
because each character
has their own storylines like
when you when you find tony or you you
know thor
or you know you're doing with the hulk
there are these
these are large chunks of story
that will be left out from uh a fan base
that paid
equal amount of money now if they're
just going to drop spider-man in there
and be like hey
a new character with with move sets
that's a good good thing then but if
you're talking about
large portions of game story
then i have a true problem with that
company charging me full
price for not a full game and i think
you're totally right on that and i think
there's an article that kind of
elaborates it's it's
it's even a detriment to to to notch his
xbox pc
also the playstation fans who do you
love spider-man because there is no way
that you take that character and give
that character
a a story because two-thirds of that
audience isn't gonna is it gonna
pay attention to it so it's kind of just
from what
the feeling is we have to see how they
introduce new characters into it
but it could be just simply like you're
a spider-man and he's
he's there now and and that kind of that
kind of sucks if you're a spider-man fan
like myself
yeah that's yeah yeah it's
it's it's i think they really dropped
the ball with that
really because the game first
when i first saw the game i was like yes
and then everybody was all down on it
because it didn't look like they're
heroes but as you grow with the game
the characters faces fit the voices
fit yeah and it's their world so
you you come to like how tony and i
really was like man this this is a
really
well done game everybody that was like
you know you know
peeing on it basically and and not
giving it a chance
give it a chance give it a chance if
well if games of a service is not your
thing
then walk away from it but also it's so
much fun to play with my friends we just
drop in and drop out
i'm the hulk and you know they pick day
characters
because i'm not getting off that
character i'm not getting off the hook
but it's fun it's a real fun game yeah i
think eventually i'm going to get into
it
just just for the story stuff none of
the uh actual game of service stuff
appeals to me
but yeah i heard the story stuff is
great so i i at least want to experience
that
i'm gonna have to wait till that goes on
game pass that's what i'm gonna
let's get these super chats real quick
we have crazy horse with the two dollars
we chat
king are we still breaking legs today
yes sir um i got a couple of knees right
here as you can see the boxes are
stacking up
nice
then we got regulated nine five one with
the two dollar super chat much respect
for gaming forte's fifteenth podcast
i've noticed that's become like a
regular joke forte yeah
are you the hardest working man in
podcast well you know what that's gonna
when we finally put the joint button on
the channel that's gonna be one of the
that's gonna be one of the emails oh
that's what's up a 10 plus podcast
that's what we're going to do
then we have we have bienna uh 8127 with
the two dollar super chat
cox spits bars and lifts them keep it up
[ __ ] will be joining us in progress at
some point uh yeah and of course you
have me lord sovereign the the player
who lives for the single player
selfish experience as i always do um i
the only thing i got to play this week
was the super mario
3d all-stars collection on my switch
and it it is what it is you know digital
so you double dipped oh yeah double
dipped i don't i'm not opening that
though
i'll tell you this though anytime you
try to
uh force scarcity on something more
often than not
it doesn't work to make it a collector's
eye more often than not you know
they probably have millions of these
they're going to sell as many as they
possibly can and they'll shut it off
artificially but i think they
still think they're selling millions of
these physical so
whatever it's not going to be a
collector's item but i got it physical
just in case
and if it's not then i'll just i'll i'll
gift it to my niece and my nephew
oh i'm playing that um you know those
games are still
great man i i'm i'm one of those people
i'm a sunshine apologist i like sunshine
it's me too
i i really love sunshine it's a pretty
game it's very different than other
mario games
uh the controls are a little weird to
get used to
um but even so i really enjoy the game
and obviously galaxy
is is a classic it's absolutely classic
and they all look great on the switch
the fact
i think the appeal is you know if you
play switch portably
it's you have them portably i can play
these games wherever i want now um and i
think that's the huge appeal of it i'm
enjoying it
um do you like how nintendo gets away
with
sending you stuff that is not enhanced
not
anything and having you charge you know
basically full price i am the biggest
fraud in the world and i'm in there
with however many millions of other
frauds oh i'm in there too i got it too
i got it i'm not i told you i was yeah
and it's that thing like they always get
a pass for that
because it's just so this is what they
do so just
just so i clarify you
you're open to give them a pass for it
i know i'm going to give them a password
whether i'm open to it or not i'll sit
here and criticize it a million times
and at the end of it i will give you the
caveat oh but i copped anyway right
the problem is nintendo doesn't the
problem is people
like saul no no no it's not how
when we talked about initially you said
i ordered three that was high i never
bought it
so you changed your mind look
it just comes down to the power of if
you got the ip you can do literally
whatever you want i was okay
with getting one until i saw mario 64
still had the resolution of the original
game
dude and then right there out the window
it's just like this and i'm like i want
the whole screen i bought well there's
an old aspect ratio and they didn't use
the emulation
uh version of like a um uh a mammy or
something like that or
uh a java you know they they left it
how it was intendedly viewed the aspect
ratio but
the resolution is higher it's definitely
crisp legit just
put three games three rhymes on the
cartridge
and in terms of game play you look at
you you look at like uh
64. and it's obviously age the worst out
of all in terms of game play
but that said like 15 minutes in it
still
felt good like the camera's the worst
they should have worked on that
but it still feels good and it it tells
you what a watermark
moment for gaming that was yeah i
remember when king
came over with his uh with his japanese
version n64
and cog and i saw that game for the very
first time
dude yo it made it almost brings tears
to the eye because we were just like nah
just saying i mean
like no way when he turned into metal
mario underwater that was that
at the end of the day man it's just
every every friend every company got one
game that she's like
i guess like mines are zelda's like they
do the same thing with zelda's
i guess next year it's coming you know
it's coming next year was that the halo
ods
well i think there's enough that's that
thing for me like the fact that i saw
them
they're putting inside the master chief
collection and it's
looking a whole lot better i was like oh
my god i think ready
there's enough zeldas to make me
there's enough zones they can do this
like three times like
especially 3d like they can literally do
one with ocarina of time and majora's
mask
and wind waker then they can do a
twilight princess
uh skyward sword i don't think there's
anyone who did it twice
they'll do it again and then after
after they released them both
individually then they put them all
together
yeah and that's exactly what i'm doing
mario right they're gonna they selling
it to you in a package for this limited
amount of time and then they're gonna
separate them all out
and then they're gonna redo them all
they're gonna redo them all yeah at some
point
i i'm sure at some point maybe we don't
live to see it they're going to remaster
uh mario 64 properly they will oh
because
i got it right here though i'm good
look at mario man look at mario back
there i told you i like you
oh you're trying to figure out where
mario no he's directly behind you
oh i thought he was on that i thought he
was on that spinner he was going to
start spinning him
oh no i didn't i did i didn't want to
turn him around and
uh i was just gonna tell the super chats
okay uh we got brap with the two dollar
super chat
king those empanadas looked on point
salute lords
then we have [ __ ] 8127 with the five
dollar super chat
jim is an idiot while pulling on xbox
crush then he unknowingly devalued all
the playstation games for the next four
years
sling pool you get covered in it uh i
don't know about the devaluing part
we'll get to it but we have cyn vendetta
with the five dollar super chat lord bad
bit be sure to preach the gospel of the
greatest game of this generation
bloodborne fear the earth
what is it please please check me on
this
it's been 2 000 in
seven days since the launch of the
greatest you know game this generation
bloodborne
i mean it's it's been a minute i'll
always out
that is a game i'll cap for the rest of
my life i will
definitely be able to throw that game in
the bushes with no return
yeah i'd like to see it at 60. i
definitely want to see that
um then did we get um demon souls
well they staying at 60. 60 for who i
for one eye
if we close one eye
i don't know how they getting 60 but i
don't know
i don't know all right then we have our
brother lord boom from double barrel
gaming with the five dollar super chat
rumor
microsoft is planning to announce series
xs price drop tomorrow
to 449.99 249.99
if this happens that'd be crazy but i
doubt that all of that happening
hey man what did phil spencer say we are
agile
in the right and i think we will
not be meek if you saw that with
the 499 and the uh 299 price
point that's not gonna happen for the
simple point uh
they're gonna sell out all these
consoles is gonna sell out
sorry go for it okay go ahead and finish
what you're saying bad [ __ ] oh
uh it's kind of like what happened with
the xbox one to me
i mean it'd be cool because i saved 50
bucks on a console but like you don't
want to
price drop a console even before it
comes out because
it despair it displays a lack of
confidence in the product
right so you want to keep it at that
price these things can
they're going to sell out both of them
like let's is a new generation
it's people that's eager to get it it's
the hot ticket items uh
for the ending of the the year so
trust and believe uh don't be fooled by
the initial sales
you know sold out all over the place
because both of them is going to do it
um it's a longevity type of thing
it's who gets to 10 million first it's
called availability people
so just you know just be happy if you
get one and enjoy it because
but price wise no you're going to pay
500.
these dudes are taking losses on these
consoles both of them
even at 299. you know yeah definitely
just to clarify man
i know i'm going to call time on
ourselves because we only got our gift
of our guests for a certain amount of
time yeah let's move on let's move on
real soon okay let's get this five
dollar sweep chat from stitch
happy to see addict in uniform only took
him four months um
like i said okay no no i ain't going to
even
look look i don't have time to argue
with you let's keep it moving
springs voices so real quick before we
get into the poll
um yeah look real quick we haven't done
um combat talk
in a long time real quick ufc last night
we in the main event we had colby
covington versus tyrone woodley
finally um listen tyra needs to it's
time to walk away man i don't know
what's up with you he's doing music
he don't care kobe is an animal and he
just walked all over
tyra and tyra and once again did not let
his hands go
i don't know what's going on dude like
this dude he just
he gets in there and feels like he
freezes and colby just
destroyed him but how the hell you
freeze with a limited crowd
how the hell are you free yeah it's just
when it's like a gym type environment
you know
um i'm sorry we got to stop making
excuses for him
we're at the point now uh when it comes
to the big show
he's going to try like to stretch out
the distance of it
and he doesn't want to take risks and i
can see you now while dana white
is really not high on the dude so uh
dana white has been right
and you know tyron i'm sorry boy just
just leave the music alone until you can
100 percent dedicate yourself to
mma stop playing around because you're
in there you can get hit
wrong and everything in your life is a
new medical alert you know so please
just
stay away from him feels like he's back
burning it and it and it shows in his
fight yeah he
doesn't feel like he's there so now walk
away um
so let's get into the results from last
week's poll um there is no new poll
because i don't have that sort of
imagination like god does so
yeah i can't be copying what colin does
though so last
the results from last week's poll are in
and the people have spoken
there you go there you go to the
question with the ps5 showcase recently
announced while this aged
quickly uh what do you think is the most
important thing for sony to accomplish
in competition with the xbox series x
slash
s power the winner
with a resounding 44.1 percent of the
vote
ps5 was match xbox series exit 500
which it did second place going to
all the smoke with 24.6 percent of the
vote
i don't care if ps5 is not shown in real
life
it don't exist yeah that's kind of true
man
so yeah i mean like what king was saying
we're seeing a lot of cgi ps5s and
we really do need to see that so it was
fun i thought of measurements on one
and i don't know if that was real
yeah i don't i don't know if that was
real to be honest with you
uh but if if that's the case that's kind
of crazy
now i know the hdmi is displayed next to
it and that could be like one of these
trolls because they show you an hdmi
and you believe oh man they got israel
the hdmi so i don't know
yeah that that wasn't exactly how cog
wrote it because i'm only looking at the
results [ __ ] has the actual script for
it so coming in
coming in in third place with 17.4
percent of the vote
spider-man miles morales gameplay and
launch which they did achieve
yeah and then coming in at uh rounding
out the voting with 13.8 percent of the
vote ps5 digital
400 or less than xbox series x which
they also did accomplish
so uh mr bad bit what do you think about
this
uh what do i think about the poll yeah
uh
yeah that's that's pretty much like the
expectations that
i was looking forward to uh the thing
that i want is them to talk to us better
yeah that's all i need to see from my uh
sorry sony
better communication but yeah no i i
really wanted to see the miles gameplay
and how that differs from
what we saw from uh you know 2018 and it
delivered
so absolutely well i mean was it on a
pro
like yeah i think
i just want to see miles in action like
that's my superhero
right so i'm i i'm so happy
yeah listen i troll a lot um and i got
you know i i see a lot of times
people put in the comments uh like this
is a xbox podcast
it's not i'm an xbox dude all right so
every member on this panel
uh plays something else other than xbox
you know like
including you yeah exactly you know i
play my playstation
you know i support people that man but i
suppose see i'm not like these shells
out here that
they try to cap for for their fan base
and try to lie to them like they're not
you know active on other things and you
know they go dark when they're playing
their games
no i you want to see me on playstation
i'm called xbox 360 level
one and i'm over there and it may sound
like a troll but so who cares
but i'm supporting more than the real
dudes that claim that they're
sony dudes like how how you don't have a
pre-order
somebody if you're a sony dude somebody
was there yeah i said the
king showed the pictures first in line
mask on ready to cut
i got my four like i got four of them
and i'm going to have your boo boo in my
house and you're going to be mad
and and i don't want to hear yo i heard
everybody switching picket lines they
crossing the picking line talking about
it's gonna be my second console now
like really dude like they
i don't care how you feel the direction
is going
they gave you what you asked for and and
yeah so what they lied to you you don't
run the company
like you're not the boss so they got to
make money obviously they need to make
money because
you're not purchasing a pro when you're
supposed to
you're not purchasing all this other
stuff when you're supposed to maybe if
you support the company
like you say you support the company
they wouldn't have to do what microsoft
is doing because
you say we don't support microsoft we
don't buy games but we buy game pass
and obviously that's a good thing so
they said you know what we're gonna go
that way
that's clearly what microsoft wants too
like they
they want everyone invested into game
pass because they want that consistent
money not all the money at once here
then all the money at once there because
they still get the third party revenue
from the seller
selling license so yup exactly exactly
let's go ahead and get these super chats
all right let's get these super chats
and we'll transition into the
to the main event we have sin vendetta
with the five dollar super chat
days since bloodborne's release on march
24 2015
is 2007 days wow that's a lot of
bloodborne love
see that i knew it it's in my head it's
implanted there it's in there
then we have perfect shogun with the 10
super chat shout out to our steam guests
i know it's been difficult securing a
ps5 this week
but nobody in this chat is going to have
a problem pre-ordering that like button
thank you sir let's hit that like button
376 watching right now let's hit that
like get the likes up
then we have regulator with the 5 super
chat sony out here frauding
how dare they announce the 400 all
digital and only 50 people get it at
launch
sony is the biggest pimp out here salute
lords yeah i mean listen man
they're losing anywhere from 60 to maybe
100
on that 400 console you are not going to
find that console
and you know what the craziest part is
king you know we'll go ahead and save it
for the first one because i i have
i have a little extra heat for sony but
i got mine
let's go ahead and do the the xbox uh
not the the giveaway thing and then
transition
okay hey guys uh sovereign has something
for you
right i think so let's see
hi this is lord sovereign from the iron
lord podcast
as you guys may recall a few months back
king david otw announced an amazing
giveaway for the xbox series x
while i'm proud to announce that the
iron lords podcast will once again be
giving away another console
at the end of this year and that console
will be a playstation
5. you heard correctly so
how do you get in on this amazing
giveaway let me explain
if you're already a member of the realm
you're good to go if you support us
either on patreon
or youtube you already have a ballot to
win this
amazing console and if you support us on
both platforms
you have two ballots to win this amazing
console as you also have two ballots to
win an xbox series x
so if you're not a member of the realm
what are you waiting for
head on over to patreon.com go to the
ironlord's podcast patreon page
become a member of the realm to get your
chance to win a playstation 5.
you can also join us on youtube iron
lord podcast
become a member of the realm and you
will also have a ballot to win a
playstation 5 console
and if you want to support us on both
platforms you'll have
two ballots for each system to win
either a playstation 5 console or of
course as king david said
and xbox series x this is an amazing
opportunity
that the iron lord podcast are so happy
to bring to our community because you
guys give so much back to us
so again if you're not a member of the
realm yet what are you waiting for
go out join the realm on either patreon
or youtube and until next time i'll see
you at the round table
said hey girls do you like to dance with
music
i can't believe someone said tender man
like that's crazy
don't swipe left on me baby
[Laughter]
[Music]
we're muted we're muted still uh
you shouldn't be talk can you hear me
guys
yeah you should be you should definitely
be live
oh my god what about now you hear us now
we haven't yeah all right we're good
yo shout out to y'all in the chat for
being messy
very very mad like y'all gave us a
contest with mario music yo
i have to say yo that video came in as
plain as can be and i handed it over to
addict and i handed it over to king
and they you know they did you know they
they their little elvis crespo on it you
know what i mean
when king when king gave me uh the
finished product i was like
why is he not talking like he's talking
like i had to go back and like
fix it so it actually like seeked up to
what he was saying
i said you know after watching the video
when it came
automatically i already had the tune
forward yeah i was like
you know um we have an incredible uh
fan base that is latino and uh you and
being that this is latino heritage month
um you know we are definitely going to
have that represented because
um i'm part latino but he's full latino
so we're definitely gonna you know like
cater to our fan base you know empanadas
[Laughter]
let me get these super chats up real
quick we got uh smitty smith with the
follow-up superhero hey can we get a
smooth like lord sob
emoji salute wow
it's 1am and i'm watching an infomercial
yo i did you new york people know about
that watching video music box at 1 am
you know
you know the videos oh yeah videos that
come on at that time
sovereign after dark look who's joined
the room
let's all get his tinder on yeah
yo i gotta say i gotta say man that as
soon as you're not on the show
these two they go they go hard on you
man they really do like oh yeah
they be extra you know they talk they
talk about how cog thinks he's too good
for us
this dude is lying that's all his
rhetoric
let's get this uh these super chats we
got squirrely dan with the 5.00
[Laughter]
no doubt that we got jonathan b with the
two dollar super chat is
giving away a ps5 or is he taking on a
date
taking something yo
but he crosses into the building
oh i was lit so we got [ __ ] adequate
[Music]
look how many people joining the realm
all of a sudden
it's it's this trucker hat man it's this
trucker yeah they came for that smoke
that's what they came for
so then we have squirrely dan with the
two dollar super chat to fix it so we
you didn't have to do that brother
then we have ego well okay first off we
have a new member of the realm chaos
sloth welcome to the realm my brother
put themselves in the chat everybody put
themselves in the chat
then we have eagles fan 76 with the five
dollar super chat
lion ryan yeah it's true game pass
subscription is not sustainable for sony
because game development costs too much
when you only have
2 million subs for ps now fax this is
true getting messy
early in the chat real messy then we
have insipid ghost luke laura with the
five dollar super chat
congrats to xbox fan mr bad bit on
hitting pirate legend much love to iop
and the incredible community
team tcl represent
i heard you getting your oled from tc
[Laughter]
look man look we we ain't talking about
i i have to
formally step down from the tcl
ambassador program all right oh yeah
he's going to be leaving the samsung
family
but right now i'm still the ambassador
because it's not here yet
today we have another member in the
realm the board game renegade welcome to
the realm sir
let's get those press in the chat i
think people want to play station five
implying they baby find one yeah
quite possibly let me explain something
uh
to the people that are for for these
giveaways right
when we secure them like if it's a hard
to get item
and we secure it you're definitely going
to get it it may not be exactly on
launch day because i don't want you to
feel like
oh i didn't get it on the 12th but if we
can get it before the 12th we definitely
have it on the 12th
or the day after two or whatever and
low-key someone secured
a a playstation 5 for me and if we
absolutely can't find one
for the realm i'll i'll use that one
well see that attic is a fantastic
person me personally i would like my
escalator
so i'm going to tell you right now are
you trying to buy me away listen
not at one point am i giving up any of
my 10
that i'm trying to make sure that i get
3k each for
uh sorry i love you
my store we're gonna make sure we get
man that's what we're talking about
because i'm going straight to where you
at
i need i need six more and i'm gonna
make sure that you get it
yes you want to escalate too don't you
all right let's get uh gerald mack with
the five dollar super chat
asking for a friend is the ps4 going to
hold back to playstation 5
because they have cross gin insert
sarcasm here much appreciate the sarcasm
uh yeah we'll be talking about that in a
little bit
then again welcome sir mozzie to the
realm
ladies and gentlemen put the press up
put them crest up in the chat people
really want that ps5 baby going in
going in and we have sin vendetta hold
up i got jumped wow sim vendetta with
the ten dollar super chat
question for forte i know gamestop won't
allow me to pre-order more than one
console per household
like a ps5 physical and a digital or
series s and x
but can i pre-order a series x and a ps5
no no wow okay so you can only pre-order
one
one three one of each console per
household but there's ways around that
yeah
clearly he can't tell you because he's a
member of the gangster realm
but lord adam can tell you get your
mamas to go in your brothers to go in
yeah but
you know something they didn't ask my
kids their address right
you know they just backed the email
yeah so i'll tell you the way it is is
they
if you have a power car if you have
powered account card yeah it will
tie your card to the pre-order so if you
go to another store
and you pre-order another one under that
same account information like your same
phone number
yeah it's tracked across all stores so
okay so don't use your power cards
because they're basically going to
cancel any pre-order like they'll keep
your initial one but they're going to
get
any pre-orders that they see that are
tied to multiple power accounts so you
can't go to different stores so
as long as it's under different
information you should be fine
but i would be on the safe side and just
have somebody else with a completely
different name
and different information just go in
there and yeah we're going in there
truckload team
on uh tuesday you know truckload team
we're gonna pull up
and uh yeah we're walking out with five
so uh
truckload team we're going in seriously
that's right truckload team
we're gonna have them trucker hats
but the question is the question is can
you order one of each though his
question is can you order playstation
and xbox
they aren't they are limiting it
completely
that's ridiculous to me like wait wait a
second wait a second what do you mean
you can't order uh because i already got
pre-ordered if you if you go in if you
go in in one shot and order them both at
the same time they'll only let you
pre-order one of them
oh no he's talking about uh okay you
can't order from the same company like
so you can't go in and order a digital
and a physical
playstation you can't go in and order uh
a series x
and uh series s no he was saying that
you can get a playstation and he didn't
want to be system yeah
right
the way that you receive it it seemed
like you couldn't get one viciousness
no you get both sisters you just can't
get both sisters
in the same family okay right just get
the hell out of me
let's get the rest of the super chats we
have the five dollar super chat all it
was missing was the scramble channel
image overlay on soft commercial
yo
[Laughter]
the wht channel um the wise old gamer
with the two dollar super chat the video
scared my kid he no longer wants a ps5
because you won't be able to find it
anyway
once again with the two dollar super
chat the video was shot on addicts tcl
yes it was
i need my camera game you should name me
on that you guys
need
then we have kids move with the five
dollar super chat cognito made me
impulse buy a
cx yeah baby let's do it old leg gang
what's going on that's not an impulse
buy that's a smart decision baby
and let's welcome to the realm mage of
lambs welcome to the realm sir let's put
those questions
around squirrely you you are you were
extra for this one man so addict we have
squirrely down with the five dollar
super chat attic went so hard with the
outfit that i traded the f-150 for the
f-350
all right so before we get into the
playstation uh topic the topic of the
day
you know god what's going on brother
what's going on man chillin chillin live
from foggy washington
what's going on how is the world burning
over there is the is the sky on fire sir
actually when i got here when i landed
they said that uh they had some rain
recently so since then
it kind of like cleared up yeah so um
it's been it's been regular just like
little foggy little rain that's good
because i know it was pretty flat over
there yeah but we chilling we're
chilling well it's cool everything's
good
i see forte i see my man in the building
what's going on
am over there
you got to set the day off listen no he
never he never stopped tonight
cognato was on vacation he wants to
drink at nine in the morning he could
drink at night
so let's get into this topic before we
do it let's get the wise old gamer real
quick with the five dollar super chat i
don't know about you
but i'm rounding up all the crackheads
for tuesday
shout out to the wow wow
all right let's get into these topics
the topic of the day ladies and
gentlemen
is the playstation 5 showcase so they're
multiple layers to this right
so let's start out with just objectively
what you guys thought about what you saw
in terms of games remove from it divorce
it from every
everything that came out afterwards
right just tell me what you thought
about the games did you like them did
you not like them
was the show weak was it so strong so uh
let's start off with mr bad [ __ ] i know
mr bad [ __ ] gotta go so
let's go and actually let me just get
these super chats real quick
apologize we got jonathan b with the
five dollar super chat cod copper oled
and start traveling the globe and
showing up late for shows
you say he's getting bougie
i never said that you know but you know
that we have only wonder gaming with the
five dollar super chat the ps5 show just
exposed the media
and gaming community and their
narratives overall this upcoming gen
looks to be special especially on xbox
then we have smitty smith with the five
dollar super chat lord cog is about to
put on the velvet smoking jacket
all right mr bad bit man yeah what did
you think about the show
uh just the showcase itself to me
walking in
sony needed to do one thing they needed
to show that road map they needed to
show you why you needed to get excited
for
the future playstation so they needed to
show you what's coming at launch they
needed to show you what's coming next
year
they needed to show you what's coming
into the future and with that
they did all of that right like final
fantasy 16 i know a lot of people
freaking out about
um that that game ain't coming out for
five years
they showed you the future that way god
of war as well uh god war
ii with the with the metroid png image
um
and then like the uh the other stuff
like definite hogwarts legacy the things
that are coming out
next year that are going to appeal to a
wider range definitely hogwarts legacy
more than any
um they needed to show that they're
willing to make those deals shake those
hands and also
get other audiences bigger audiences
looking at this event so that's why you
saw the call of duty uh single player
event there
that's why you saw five seconds of
fortnight it's to get those audiences
looking at what's gonna happen this
generation and kind of yeah
trick them into thinking oh this is the
place to this is the place to be since i
can't play fortnite on my iphone
let's go let's go roll the dice
somewhere else so
to me they nailed it with the showcase i
thought it was a really solid show
my favorites out of it is definitely
miles morales
um they needed they needed to show me
why
why why i need to get a playstation 5
but now looks like you could just
but like real talk though like they
wanted to show you why you got to have
this platform
this is this is the way to do it um moz
morales looked a lot of fun
whether it's a dlc or not like seeing
that combat looks
really really nice to be honest um
i wasn't the biggest fan of like the
2018 one but that combat looked a lot
more interesting than
whatever i played absolutely yeah it
looks like it's ditching the the
the the gadgets with abilities so you're
using that that venom strike
like like a grenade or like a chain aoe
ability so like you're playing with his
abilities in really unique ways which is
really cool
and of course for vendetta out there my
the the thing that i've been watching on
repeat
is demon souls that that demo was
i love how they're just like have it on
one hit mode because we need to get
through this fast
but like that really showcased the fast
loading
that they wanted to show off so when
you're going from point a to point b
it's instantaneous even when you're
traversing through fog
it was really fast so yeah you didn't i
didn't see that
long pause right exactly it was just
like right into the right into the
moments of gameplay
so and that's a launch title and that is
the thing that's really
getting me through the door because as
though i'm gonna be real
never play demon souls i'm into
bloodborne i love that game that's
what's gotten me into the soulsborne
genre and i've played most of the most
of the game
since so i want to go back to the
original beat
the thing that started it all seeing
blue point
unknowing their pedigree i am so
into this game man so to me the showcase
hit on all the levels it needed to hit
um
but it's the aftermath and that's the
map yeah
and that's why the topic's called the
afternoon yeah
all right i i agree i think uh in terms
of demon souls
it really it needed to be there at
launch same with miles so i was happy
about that
um but we'll get we'll get to four taste
thoughts on it
um so forte you were on the live stream
with the with the lords
and i purposely didn't listen to too
much of it because i wanted to get
raw reactions today from what people
felt that day so i kind of
quick overview um but i didn't hear
everything that everyone had to say so
tell me what you felt about the uh
about the showcase so my um
my thoughts haven't changed from the
moment that i saw it till now because i
can separate what happened after the
fact from it
i think it's really by far the best show
they hate what's happened this year
i think this show was literally a
blueprint
to show other companies how you do a
digital event online
in the middle of a crazy world that
we're in right now
i think the top the talking points were
on point i can probably say a lot of
some of the games they showed towards
the end lost a little bit of steam just
because they were just throwing it was
like filler
that people didn't really care about
which that where the show dragged itself
down with
but when you show gameplay of miles
morales and you're showing off
that ridiculous combo system and just
i i never thought they could actually up
like
literally uplift what they did with
marvel spider-man when they showed the
cinematics the first time
in game play they literally did this
with the bridge scene and i was like bro
if you're not excited to play this game
there's really something wrong
because even if you're not interested in
this type of game it just makes you want
to
it just literally makes you want to play
it and then demon souls i'm not a i'm
not i'm nowhere near a demon souls fan
but just looking at that i was like
wow i remember what the old one looked
like
nothing none nothing like that it's a
completely different game
a different game and it to me they
really hit it out the park when it came
to
like bad bit said the first part the
messaging they sold you
on what the place what you can expect
when it comes to
playstation now we all thought this was
playstation 5
it comes to find out that it's also just
playstation in general
which is still a good thing because it
still entices you to want to be in that
ecosystem
and i think that's all they really
technically want you to be
and that was good i gave it a 8.5 out of
10. i think it was
really really on point they gave us the
price
they gave us release date they botched
on the pre-order thing
but they gave you pre-orders in it so
they gave it all to you in one failed
swoop
it was just the aftermath that took the
took all the air out of it but for me
show was great he had fun in there and
um
i think a lot of people really enjoyed
what they had the show during that um
event
absolutely absolutely let's get to super
chat real quick before we head on to
addict
can't say uh gerald mack with the five
dollar super chat can't say you've been
drinking all day unless you start in the
morning
welcome to the west side lord cognito
shout out to the lord
you know what time it is
skip over attic first let's go to
cognito
spicy what did you feel about the show
this week
yeah i got a chance to rewatch it again
and um baby's making some great points i
mean
on face value when you look at how the
show especially how the show
started it was really heavy hit after
having hit it i thought um obviously
miles showed well
you know then you go you got demon souls
you got um
i thought i thought actually was
underrated was the uh the harry potter
hogwarts oh because at the end of the
day that's going to appeal to a big
audience right
so i thought that was smooth i like what
they did there the i agree with
forte in the middle it started to drag a
little bit there was some
questionable decisions i felt like i
didn't know why fortnite was there
it was like um it was like another game
because they made the devil
thank you that kind of pissed me off
i didn't want that to be there he
doesn't correct such a good role
with new stuff exclusive and then i
liked how they use the vervice like from
this point on
everything you're going to see is
playstation 5 on gameplay so
they were taking the cues of what
everybody was kind of upset about
and i like that you know what i'm saying
but as we know it's because the lords
went live
and everybody as the information started
to come out
then we started to see the show
deteriorate and we started to see
things fall apart i don't know if we get
into this with this topic
oh yeah we'll we'll get into it i just
want to get everybody's general sort of
feeling first and then
the smoke will come afterwards so yeah
okay
as a show i thought what they had to
show was fine
you know i'm saying and minus a little
one or two three mishaps and then they
did what they did really well i thought
the end
is vintage sony you know the one more
thing
and yes it wasn't jpeg i know can't go
kill him but at the end of the day
no i'm not gonna okay well you can't ken
you're gonna kill him
on the year because you would i think
you would rand do not believe
no no no you're gonna be very surprised
with what i gotta say oh okay okay
so at the end of the day i thought that
was vintage you know what i'm saying you
give your fans a taste
of one more thing and that part was dope
so overall that's where i'm at with it i
probably have to rewatch i'm still like
7.5 ish with it because again selfishly
because my gaming is a selfish thing
those most of those games are not for me
as far as the launch window
you know what i'm saying but overall i
know that demon souls have i mean miles
with me but demon souls is going to
appeal
to a huge baseline that's what i think
it is definitely is it definitely is
lord addict what are your thoughts
take a deep breath first off i want to
say i apologize to the chat
i forgot to have to mute on obs if i
talk because normally uh
i'm not on the obs part so i definitely
apologize for that in my conversation
about
what to eat for breakfast but all right
so
you know one thing i want to bring up is
i i didn't really enjoy the show like i
enjoyed some of the announcements
but i felt like the show itself wasn't
even that impressive it was okay
like if you really think about it the
only thing that really applied to me
was the beginning which was spider-man
miles that surprised me because
you guys all know how i felt about you
know this spider-man game
and then demons so at the end like what
about what about final fantasy though
what'd you think about it
i actually do i wasn't feeling final
fantasy like
and it wasn't the fact that i just they
they obviously went away from turn base
but i was like you know they exchanged
turn base with how the game looked i
still don't agree with that decision
but at least i knew the game was going
to look impressive i didn't think the
game looked impressive i thought
it looked mean like the fire animations
look like early this gym
sure the combat looked a little bit
closer to final fantasy 7 than 15.
but that didn't even look that
impressive like did did you like the
return to sort of the fantasy settings
i liked
yeah i was about to say final fantasy
used to be about crystals of the
elements
that you have to protect and they went
away from that for years and this is one
of the very first games that they went
back to that so i was okay with that
that was fine but as far as everything
else i just
i wasn't feeling it like and then like
not to mention like 30 minutes in the
middle the show was
was i didn't dude
like i didn't care
no it wasn't it was at the beginning it
was the second thing see
well you know what's crazy you know
what's crazy hold on you gotta remember
final fantasy was like six minutes of it
let them know man let
[Laughter]
[Music]
that that's how bad it was it was this
miles was the second game they showed
and forte said is at the middle of the
show
okay so yeah it's just like
i i just didn't i wasn't filling the
majority of the games there god award
was
one of the biggest games they showed and
we got a jpeg obviously i didn't expect
much more
but we can't we let's be real we can't
go at people like nintendo for showing a
jpeg
a metro like six years ago and just let
sony get away with that
but that's the thing though they showed
jpeg and they say 2021 it's like
well that's not coming out 2021 let's be
realistic
you know what i'm i'm gonna give you a
realistic take on that 2021
which possibly might happen let's go
okay so
let's get into king's thoughts king you
had a couple of days to sit on this
and let it let it percolate somewhat so
i gave you two stars and i'm i have to
take one way
oh all right and let me explain why this
is a selfish gaming experience right
um and i said that and they needed to do
a couple of things and they they
basically pretty much
did most of the stuff that i was talking
about but we're talking about the show
itself right we're not we're not going
to go into i like to give you price
great good that's great um
miles i told you they needed to have
miles
yes they did it and you know uh i think
people would like to be a prisoner of
the moment and don't really know what a
milestone
uh game that uh 2018 was
um and and and the combat i didn't see
too much different from the original
combat to be honest with you i just saw
a different character doing different
moves right right and um so i'm not
going to jump on the hyperbole train
but what i would say is i've always been
excited for miles
that was the only reason for me to get a
playstation
and it stays the only reason for me to
get a playstation now when somebody says
something like demon souls
demon souls never appeals to me right
and i and i've
learned that by trying to get what was
that
well but it looks great see i'm not
going to fall in that trap no more i
don't
i don't have 70 to give you for your
trap
you understand so it's not good you're
not fooling me
any longer no it's not going to be a
game that i'm going to purchase to pop
in to say
look how pretty it is there's nobody in
my house to see
how pretty it is it's just me
regardless what this game is it's still
a
it's still a remake like should we be
paying 60 dollars for that like well no
it's 70 bucks
oh yeah and and i did see somebody put
up a stream
of the first one in the second and i
mean like the drums is incredible
but then while i'm watching that and not
to take away not because we we're just
talking about how we feel about the show
we can go into the aftermath later but
um how i felt about the show is
if i saw any game that i was interested
in
it was a multiplat right so
i i said okay well i got to take away a
minus from that because i'm not
purchasing from them so this is a sony
show
what did i take away from sony's show i
took away miles
and yes miles is truly tremendous and i
took away a price point
and i'm like yeah yes this is it we are
here now
and then they gave you the the
pre-orders will go
tomorrow okay so now that you're giving
me somewhat of a
a road map i can roll with you guys and
when i say it's a one for me i'm talking
about games across the board that they
showed that i was excited for
all right so i can't tell you that i'm
going into the
to the store and i'm going to say you
know give me bug snacks and give me this
and give me that i'm not
i'm going to say give me miles and i'm
walking out the door
and that's where your purchasing power
ghosts
now when i saw god of war and they said
2021 i was looking for them to say 2023
when they say 2021 now now what you're
telling me be
in light of what has been transpiring
lately
uh that now what i was telling you from
the beginning
from the rip they're not chucking out
old assets these games cost
x amount of dollars to make this is not
1986 guys
where okay we're going to go on to the
next game it's going to take five years
to develop no we're going to use the
same assets that we use
because we developed this this stage we
developed this
world in spider-man and we're going to
change the character we're going to give
a different storyline but we're going to
grow it
from the existing textures existing
material existing world so
stop capping thinking it was built from
the ground up
special stuff it's not
i think about some certain scenarios was
done
to where it was new you know what i'm
saying but no no no no no no there's no
let me finish let me feel yeah
even if these textures were made from
the ground up it still
represents something that's already made
like it's not like they
made new avatars from scratch because
most the majority of the game
i assume i've never played demon souls
it's going to be what was in the first
one just highlighted it looks better
yeah i i can get to that too but when
they show god of war
is horizon two running with the same
assets
you know um because the turnaround is
pretty close
so you're saying if the turnaround is
next year
or close to it
all these games that we're seeing even
when you
you yell out ratchet and coin looks so
incredible
i've played i actually went upstairs and
played the first one all over i said
well i got a lot of boards that look
just the same
they're using the same assets the same
worlds the same
algorithms and yeah you paint you put
more npcs here you you're prettying it
up your particle effects racing all that
stuff it's
but it is at its core building stuff
off of that game yes so everybody's
yelling out oh man insomniac is the
hardest working dude to know
insomniac is the dudes that turned into
mortal kombat and they re-skinning stuff
you know you got cyborg and you got uh
uh cyrax and you got molina and you got
katana
this is what they're doing all right so
the king has already gotten into the
smoke part in the aftermath part of it
so let let's go i know i can't
i'll let king elaborate more as we move
into it i want to go first
i i want to all right but remember we
got bad bit only for a little while long
yeah
that's a bad bit i i want to go after a
bad bit then because
okay i have stuff in my mind i gotta get
out
and in case you haven't noticed and in
case he doesn't want to just deal he
don't want to
in case you haven't noticed my voice is
already going out
so yeah but i gotta get my bars off i
got you i got
you all right so lord bad [ __ ] the name
of the show today
is the aftermath right because the
aftermath is where all
all the good stuff happened right we
enjoyed the show
there was some great showings but for
sony first party stuff
but there was stuff that was weirdly
missing
from the actual show proper and their
details have started to trickle out as
the show concluded
that sort of put a a little bit of a
damper
on what we had seen already so uh let's
get into your thoughts on that the
aftermath but real quick
because y'all got two people that join
the role yes we do motivate and delilah
no doubt shout out to hustle the
motivate welcome to the realm my brother
put them crushed in the chat and of
course lady delilah welcome to the realm
put them crushing the chat thank you so
much for joining the room we appreciate
it
so question lord bad bit tell me what's
your playstation nation baby
what did you feel so i i
man there's a lot of feelings none of
them are good um
i guess i gotta say this uh you know
look i know i host
a trophy room playstation podcast right
i'm supposed to
talk all nice and positive no it's not
it's not been fun it hasn't been a great
experience
um so like i'll tackle first the
pre-order bit
uh i see a lot of people falling back on
it's the retailer's fault it's the
retailer's fault that the pre-orders
happen this way
um whether it's they leaked it out first
you know whether they broke embargo
or not yes retailers are at fault for
doing that but
at the end of the day that fault hangs
on sony's shoulders
they should have at that pre-recording
show and i'm finding my sinuses
at the same time here but at that show
they should have said hey pre-orders are
up at friday
name a time right at that show so that
people knew
not after the fact not on twitter not
not this guessing game that happened
for for you know 48 hours look
i had to hunt down i i'm recording a
podcast
and at the same time trying to hunt down
a digital ps5
like that's how best it was guys it was
awful there's no
sugar coating digital i went digital
yeah yeah
i'm done with the physical life okay so
you went digital not
knowing exactly what the hard drive
space is
yeah because i usually get an external
anyway okay so you're gonna pay the
extra five hundred dollars i got you
sure
yeah exactly
not like real like real talk my ps5 is a
graduation gift
so i'm splurging all out on it i got
that that's just me
so uh so with that said though
like the way that i pre-ordered it
through playstation on one of jim's
chosen ones
was
it's not mine so like that's how it
should have been
but the fact that they they totally
totally
just dropped the ball it's embarrassing
and when it comes to
you know miles sac boy and horizon zero
or horizon 2 being ps4 ps5 and being
cross
gen that is just deceitful
that is just lies that is just bs
so so let me let me ask you this um
obviously it's deceitful because of what
they said they were doing what they
promised
but you personally is that something
that bothers you is that is that a
square that you stood on like
listen man like yes oh so you absolutely
believed in hey
i i want these this cut in generations i
don't want
i don't want to be held back by anything
exactly and my co-host
was not like that he's very much like
you know like with
with uh with xbox's moves he liked it
with this one he was fine with it but
for me i'm just like no no
no no no no if jim came out and said
if jim came out and said in in june
going yes you know
we believe in generations but for the
first year here's how everything's going
to roll out
it's going to be us a a slower
move or transition into the playstation
5 because we have 100
plus million ps4s we have to still
respect that audience too
fine fine just tell me that but don't
give me this bullcrap of like
oh everything is you know everything's
built from the ground up
because i know for a fact immediately
after horizon one
they were working on horizon two midway
through development
they were given ps5 dev kits so like i
already know that that's nonsense
it's nonsense and the thing about it is
like what hurts about this situation is
this
they sat there and they they saw
the the vitriol that phil spencer got
after he made his statements right they
saw that
and they immediately do what sony does
but sony's very good at reacting
and and taking and taking the reactions
of the public
and using it to their advantage they saw
the vitriol
that that phil spencer got as a result
of saying look we
we we don't we want to transition
smoothly we want people not to be
feel like they're being left behind and
immediately they came out and said we
believe in generations
this game is going to be on this
platform these are going to be here and
so
the thing about it is that it is a
blatant lie right it's not that
they recorded this video knowing full
well what they were doing
and that's what is the worst about it
right because i all these companies lie
to us in some way shape or form they
don't
love you they want they love your dollar
that's what you care about
so that doesn't bother me the fact that
this was so
blatant and it was blatantly to take
advantage of
what they saw was happening to phil
spencer online is is
is what really uh feels it feels icky it
feels really
really icky yes and then that's my
that's my whole problem with like the
showcase was great
everything after the fact though muddies
all of it
and so like that said like i would be
fine if it like
because rumors was for a very long time
and it totally makes sense hindsight
2020 that
miles would be a multi multi you know
console launch because
look the only person benefits from miles
being
ps5 is sony right marble isn't gonna
they want the biggest check possible if
you're marvel so
i totally get if that's a ps42 but again
if if jim just came out and
said hey listen we believe in
generations but for the first year you
can expect
this from us a smooth transition from
ps4 to ps5 whatever
there's a million different pr ways as a
pr person
to tackle that way better we would have
been on this board
we would have been on the bandwagon and
after hearing all of that
because as as someone who covers
playstation i'm not a
fan of playstation i appreciate them i
love games like
you know luke luke in the chat i'm a
pirate legend sea of thieves
how many how many how many people here
are pirate legends
right like like once you put a
controller in my hands
i'm going to play that game right so
like
as someone who's who straight up covers
it i'm watching it after the fact
and i i do like to bring up that uh he
did beat me in halo wars 2
so yeah there you go
so with that and it was a good match
like it is
to me i when i was seeing all that roll
live i was just like i wonder how
the fanboys are going to react to it and
it is so interesting to see
the people that were you know defending
playstations we believe in generations
halo's being held back narrative
um and just see them go silent yes
and just like not say anything can't say
anything you can't say anything and then
a couple of days later they tried to
spin it or whatever that was
they were those that tried to spin it
you know and try to run with it
um and then there were some that really
admitted i got to give a shout out to
puerto rico puerto rico
he means himself because he was like huh
what like
so i mean they were they were there was
people had that had difficulty accepting
there were a lot of different reactions
to but in general i think everybody
was taken aback by the fact that the lie
was so blatant
so um that that was the craziest part
about it so listen i think it was more
abrupt
yeah not blatant i think the abruptness
of it
it's like yeah man i don't care anything
about that red right there man
yo pass me that red hat bro
[Laughter]
it was it was a move like that so before
we give it to attic let's get these
super chats real quick we have the
the wise old gamer with the five dollar
super chat this is the millennium
of aftermath it ain't gonna be nothing
after that so give me one more platinum
plaque
and fps five you can have it back wow
okay and then let's get the crust in the
chat for justin russell welcome to the
realm
sir let's get some crust in the chat
thank you so much
and everybody trying to get that
playstation 5 baby i feel you man hey
show your hat in the ring yeah they just
swat in the suave
edition of the ps5 yo
face
all right so we have stitch with the
five dollar super chat for those of you
that got a ps5 digital
there's a workaround to be able to play
your ps4 go to your local preferred
store and get yourself a psn card
you're about to join me cognito and uh
king david on the memes because you know
people about to pick apart that
i knew
[Laughter]
the floor is yours sir look there's a
couple things that i felt like is really
bad okay first off
i want to bring up something i don't
really see people bringing up
sony has low key made a cheaper console
but don't intend to sell it to the most
people like they're like okay
you know we can't do this we can't do
this this this price thing man
we got to make it lower but but but that
that lower one's going to cost us a lot
of
money oh oh all right let's just only
like print like 10 percent
like the another 90 is going to be the
physical like
forte it's you tell when you were
talking
you told me that the fit the digital was
was
was way less than the physical didn't
you
yeah it's like it's like five to one
so so to me it's like they're using it's
like they
they use the three that system to hit a
price point
just to have the narrative saying that
we have a system at that price
they never intended no one touches those
ceilings
well real talk it's a little bit a and b
it's one it's like they they definitely
under uh they yeah they they want it for
the price
as well as the fact that most real
retailers especially gamestop and this
is something we're talking about on the
trophy room
of like if we were going to be surprised
if they even sold this thing
because it's literally like selling a
goodbye to your customer
so from what i understand a lot of
retailers just didn't want the digital
in the first place so i was very lucky
when i when i am one of jim ryan's
chosen
uh those digitals being
sold on uh through playstation directly
because yeah like if your game stop why
why do i want digital
to me oh real quick real quick i missed
the wise old gamers uh one of them one
of the super chats we have uh two dollar
super staff and wise old gamer
looks like the ps4 still has some miles
in it haha
like wow well played sir well
yeah we got more uh
then we have e murray with the five
dollar super chat let's also add that
now
the ps4 is going to be supported for
four years that's two more than the xbox
one consoles
i mean that i mean listen i gotta give
it to aaron greenberg and it wasn't him
like he just he put the little eyes on
it
immediately posted that the xbox series
x
now or the xbox platform now has the
most confirmed
next-gen exclusive and that that's crazy
because
you know me and laura cognito we were
talking like like
microsoft and sony have low-key flip
scripts
microsoft is the person like we're gonna
we're go you know
everyone's gonna stay together we're all
gonna circle we're all going to spin
around the circle no one's getting left
behind
and then and then we do that showcase
and they're like
everyone's getting left behind they're
like they're like
you see this halo this is the only game
you get you only get in this halo
and then obviously like a month later
like you ain't getting the halo anymore
fam like
because because it's just like it's
crazy because sony used to be the other
way around
every game is going to be exclusive we
we believe in generations
a month later everyone's getting the
games with playstation 4's getting the
games
we're going to get pc demon souls and
then act like it never happened
but that's the thing like i understand
like look the ps2 was supported for 17
years
so like when they're like we're going to
support the ps4 i'm like oh so you're
going to get more
you know some more multi-players you're
going to see maybe a year or more of
call of duty a couple years of mad and
all that but then like how can you
how can you believe that when jim ryan
has already
just like he asked you three times in an
afternoon he's
a liar
we're coming at phil spencer saying
how's phil spencer goes he flip-flops on
what he says and stuff
y'all talking about something that i've
seen that timeline of that tweet like
over the last
four or five years of all the things
that phil fister said
i was like i said jim ryan literally
passed that up in an afternoon
you know the crazy part is a lot of the
times when these corporations flip
script and their messaging gets weird
it's it let's be real it's from feedback
like
you know a lot of people was like we
want exclusive
next-gen experiences i was one of those
people
and then what happened
oh my god
at the end of the day you know with this
whole playstation
and you know miles coming to playstation
4.
who did that for you it was phil spencer
it's just like look like you know we've
said it multiple times
uh when it comes to stuff like this is
business i think that
something happened among the lines
because i don't think this was going to
be the narrative every
like i don't think this was always going
to be the narrative
but i do think something happened and
they changed they changed scripts
because
this isn't just a little bit of a
mixture of messaging
scripts but at the end of the day we
have to acknowledge that those games
have been in development
the playstation 4 version of miles the
playstation 4 version of horizon zero
dawn
you know what way development works from
the just from the jump
that means they sat on this watch what
phil in them did to see the reaction
yeah and said to themselves
no you know and that here's the thing
the most egregious part and i
we gotta state it is none of this was
stated
during the conference we had to find out
after the fact you know for you yeah
what's crazy
before the podcast started and before we
did that reaction
we had people telling us some stuff was
about to happen in the vlogs afterwards
but we thought it was going to be
different stuff like yo
twitter ain't never been so lit that's
like that's right
right that's why it's the deception the
ultimate deception ultimate lie because
even us who are in the know if we watch
that show
you didn't know anything about a
playstation 4 version of anything right
you didn't know anything about the
pre-order so you walked away thinking it
was just as it always was
and then you get the statement from him
afterwards and the blog post jeff keaton
and all that
and that's why there's so much vitriol
they sat on it
they knew the reaction would be negative
and they left me real i gotta shout out
the xbox too shout out to brandon
they didn't have the balls to put it out
there because they knew what was going
to happen
let me say this real quick that's why
you got to give respect like i said it
in the last video i made i was like look
phil spencer in them knew what they were
going to do and and they came out openly
they're like look like
some of you ain't going to like our
moves and we get that that's why we want
to be transparent from the start
and at this point it's like i was
telling cognito
sony has lost the right to have faith in
anything they say
because this isn't just something small
they have literally
lied about the entire marketing for
playstation 5
since the get-go imagine when the miles
was first announced how many times did
people ask them on twitter is this
coming to ps4
remember the stream the live stream the
first thing out of my mouth was
what is this the moment i saw miles
morrison what
is this here's the thing what made it
more egregious was we weren't even
allowed
he they built up their fan base to
believe this so much that we weren't
even allowed to question
because he was like remember me attic we
didn't all of us
all on the front lines like yo is it a
full game why is it not spiderman
is it an expansion what is it oh no it's
definitely a full standalone game but
definitely this is definitely that and
then the executive came out
and said it and then he was like oh are
you going to believe that let's believe
that
the the the studio and the developer
over the executive that is
i forgot about how they shut him down
because low-key the european vice
president already snitched the
information out
like yo it's a ps4 game with upright
assets and they're going to take
advantage of certain things on ps5
but lowly us but how dare us challenge
this right
remember we got killed on social media
so we've been
asking what the structure of this action
game was
to those of you who believe that demon
souls isn't coming to ps4
and pc i have a bridge to sell you
because
at the end of the day when it comes to
the demon souls the the person who
that's their own
trailer that's not a third-party trailer
people are trying to sit there and say
addict it's they messed up they put
their place the final fantasy one so
it's score ethics made the final fantasy
one not playstation
you're gonna tell me we're gonna be
super chat real quick but you're gonna
tell me that you they didn't watch
over that presentation 50 times to see
if it was correct
you're going to tell me that just slip
you know what's funny is
if if something like that just like that
trailer that little tinder trailer that
we just
promoted of sovereign i've watched that
gosh
i watched that like six seven times this
morning to make sure
everything was fine like you needed to
tell me
that i have more cause of i the sodium
multi-million dollar corporation
and also when you look at that that that
showcase
like let's also speak another truth here
how rushed it was
that's right like you could see you
could see mistakes
in premiere as it was going live yeah
like
souls right it did it didn't have to
clear it up there was so many
not just not just that cog but there's
literally
five seconds where it should have that
they should have said
uh and launch you know on playstation
here's the date
but they didn't do that you just see a a
straight up four seconds of
just a block screen of just nothing that
consoles coming out this year
honestly you know imagine yo that would
be horrible
let's get these people attached sorry
fast back with the 10
super chat the messaging on everything
ps5 next gen not so greatness
crossgen ssd expansion pre-orders no
matter gaming looking great no matter
the platform hashtag series x day one
with my 4k
tcl on my knees lord king
you got you got these man you get the
apologizing tv
[Laughter]
then we have clutch man with the two
dollar super chat these aftermath
podcasts made this week
fly by yeah oh yeah it was late
i said on twitter i said on uh i almost
said tinder because all this tinder
talking i said on twitter
i said on twitter that uh i was i'm
watching every podcast this week it
don't matter who you are you getting an
addict view
are you getting a like unless you say
something off the wall stuff you ain't
getting a like but you're at least
getting the view because i want the
smoke
so that we have uh we have chaos sloth
with the five dollar super chat
sony just took a page from shaggy's
playbook is all fans came in and saw
playstation creeping on the net on the
last gen ps4
jim ryan was like wasn't me
[Laughter]
it wasn't me oh god hold on i got jumped
a little bit
let me see new members of the room
yeah we got new members of the room hold
on okay i got the shaggy one then we got
clutch man again with the five dollar
super chat
you right king jim ryan tried to sweep
it away smooth like turbo with the broom
robot do the robot sure
and let's welcome to the realm noob
cybot
oh oh yes put those comments
yeah let's go let's get it and we have
hold on a second let me make sure we got
jonathan b with the five dollar
chat tender moments would solve 4k
announcements he's a ps5 exclusive
wow yeah i i could see i thought i was
going to avoid the means
but someone's going to like screenshot
it
i know i knew i was gonna get these
hands eventually so they got regulated
with the two dollars in the chat
pray for christopher hart over here
damage controlling yeah
there's nothing that he could say that
could stop
what happened you know what's crazy well
let me just say something real quick
little crazy how many
when we saw that little snippet of
gameplay in that showcase me and you was
like
that's a that looks ps4 all over you no
it's not it's got the ssd
secret sauce it's in there
we all know what cinematics are right
and all i said was we haven't seen the
game yet
like let's see not that the game is
gonna be whack but at the end of the day
let's can i get two of those please
because
i'm tired of design talk
i'm tired did we get your brain and
corbin though
i'm tired i'll get into it i'll get it
don't worry is ssd
only possible because of talk
that is in the bushes now we can now get
back to just look at that game
and appreciate what they are exactly
i was tired all these fake armchair
developers trying to say that this is
the advantage that this system has over
another system
to shame another people like that let's
just stop it let's stop
now but just thought all the particle
effects were on the arm
was due to the ssd speed they was able
to get
more particles to the
did you hear lord lord landing right he
was talking about his odd world game
saying that it could only be done on
playstation
you know what's crazy little cognato i'm
actually hearing like
a lot of these hardcore sony fanboys
they're they're going the extra mile to
continue this narrative
they're saying there's going to be a ps5
version and a ps4 version
and there's gonna be no features in the
ps5 version
yeah it's called
you know and whatever that that's that's
fine my thing is
you lied about it if you have been
through the beginning we would have been
fine
the ponies would have had to deal with
it they would have had months to get
over it
you know what i mean um i'll get into my
points later let's get brandon corbin
let me get phase 23 because he's still
trying to fight this he said the
steven's souls were actually clank
destruction on ps4 wait wait is
brother
you know if he want to live that tcl
life god bless
you know what's crazy i'm pretty sure
that you have shade chris chris hart
multiple times and just super chatty i
don't think i've ever seen this man
super chat but our show he's like
can't get in this work you know what
he's gonna stupid chat over here
because i'm the only person that
actually really friended him and really
support the dude
right you know all these fake uh
playstation generals these
playstation bosses they don't even have
a pro
they don't even have a playstation 5
pre-order these dudes that
they're out here capping talking about
the ssd speed
and all that he's really out here front
line you're a general
you're a boss i like your bars better
yeah
tell me how so in general tell me
respect those who definitely
admit it right you know whatever tony
this is wrong
you lied you said you would believe and
there were a bunch of them they were and
they were
they had no choice but you know if they
wanted to be
on twitter they had no choice
king you're gonna love this one shout
out to fonz he said
you know you know what the exclusive is
gonna be for the ps5 the exclusive ten
dollar feature
you're gonna pay ten dollars more for no
extra fee
exclusively ten dollars more all right
let's get these two two
stats and then we'll go to forte from
brandon corbin with the five dollar
super chat
can one of y'all explain to me how is
miles morales and horizon 2 a next-gen
game
uh if they have to run on 2013 hardware
this is for the pump me
it's it's not an exciting game it's a
ps4 game that has a ps5 port
though because of the three or four
years developers
i don't know anything anything that
comes out in that first three-year
window i think it's going to it's full
and
pc as well and the crazy thing is you
know we don't
even if sony came out right now during
this park as like it's for the ps5
they they they haven't earned they they
no longer have the right to us to
believe them
not sony we don't have to wait for the
game to launch now
it's credibility it's true credibility
at this time they've lost a lot of them
jim then showed up and shot their
credibility in the foot
oh you know what i've got a new regime
we can't trust him
no i told you that from the date yo
listen man y'all think i i
i was trying to show you i was trying to
bring light to your darkness
yeah y'all wanted to sit there in the
dark and y'all didn't want to
listen to what i was saying you had ear
muffs on in the closet that's how they
want you
they want you stuffed in a corner quiet
and very
obedient they don't want you looking
they don't want you listening
and they damn sure don't want you
talking so when
they tell you when when this whole
pedigree
is one way and he gets there he acts
like he's another way
he was fraudulent from the jump and i
told you he was going to be complicit
he is absolutely 100 percent a student
of
phil he's part of the sith he had it
he's not under filled he's under
fulfilled
king like he had it for a week and made
major changes
like he has done more major changes in
six
months well i think he's doing that
because he's been in there for like nine
months now
he's a businessman he is done he has
done more in nine months
than phil has done in six years and the
king's credit
that's what king has been preaching all
along like i can't wait to show him why
this
is up and i should wrap it here so i got
a shout out you know everyone's talking
about track record and all this stuff
yeah what happened to that track record
this is a new regime and we have to
tell them because god forbid xbox fans
know
when the donny magic regime started it
was different they went peterborough so
we got to see how this guy moves
from this point forward donny tried to
throw us
under the butt donnie tried to destroy
the ship donnie tried to titanic us
this gym move jim dance moves ryan is
donny d's
incarnated like he's really keeping his
whole movement y'all in trouble baby the
thing is when everybody gets over being
butt hurt over this right when everybody
gets home
at the end of the day in terms of the
business more like
and like we were just saying we don't
know what changes also come down the
line that may not be favorable at all
right
if you were standing on that square
always that look
i love this playstation platform because
i get things here that i cannot get
anywhere else and they tell me that
once i switch from one platform to the
next in the same family
i'm not they're not going to be holding
my games back if you stood on that
square
you have to get over that it's over it's
done nothing that comes out of their
mouth in regards to that
is ever going to be trustworthy again
period
let it go now right that said as a
business decision what they're doing oh
small yeah
they're smart and and in that in that
way playstation became stronger
right because playstation is going to be
making
even more money hand over than where
before like
how many people exactly so how much does
the company have to do between now and
then
i'll be honest i'm surprised it took
this long for it to happen because
place listen you have you have stockholm
you have shareholders you have
you have a board of directors you have
to answer to at some point
and again i got to give to microsoft
right when microsoft pivoted
to to to us a subscription model and to
services
everybody would laugh and like oh well
they're doing it because they have no
choice they're losing right right
microsoft are usually the ones that take
when they have to pivot and change the
pac
and create a paradigm shift in gaming
they're usually the first ones to put
their face out there
they get destroyed for it and at the end
of the day whether it's a year later
five years later we find out that's
exactly the way the industry was going
right
this is the same thing this is the same
thing microsoft went out there they got
ridiculed for it they're like this is
not for us this that and the other
and this is what happened with
playstation and
again you you have to understand these
people
these these board of directors they do
not care about your wallet garden
they don't care console war they care
about
the bottom line and it's miraculous
that it has taken this long right and
when microsoft made that shift it was
only a matter of time before sony would
follow suit
i'm not saying just long game do you you
know what's crazy too
is a lot of the these board members they
own
stock and sony like they want the
company to do better so they become
richer like jim is going nowhere yeah
absolutely i don't think he is
not at all he's the best liar he's the
best
dancer and he's the best business
business
man that they had in charge he's not
beholden to your old philosophies and
your archaic
views he's not beholden to your thoughts
on how the company should be run
and he doesn't value ips as much as you
think he
values i he doesn't give a damn about
the ips at all he won't care about
monetizing them
he's going to make sure that those ip he
wants
god of war being played in the tesla
trust me when i'm telling you
he definitely wants to make bread he
wants to be the most successful
playstation head that ever lived and i
told you when he dropped the price of
the playstation now i want to see the
difference from when he took over
and what's happening right now with
playstation now
did they go up in subscriptions i want
to know exactly
what was the revenue change from when he
took office
to where he's at now and i guarantee you
by the end of next year when those games
start coming day and date on that pc
and you understand that he has a game
pass thing that's inside
uh that playstation universe what
the hell y'all got going over there and
you're gonna subscribe to that
and the price goes up a little bit more
to get inclusion
he's going to adapt what makes money and
he
is not apologetic about it and he has no
problem
doing a 360 or 180 right in front of
your
face he does not care because at the
bottom line is
the board of directors is over his head
and he's
he is uh what is it uh challenged
and he is uh tasked with bringing
them money so he's not there for you
for the all years the players of the
board
the person microsoft does a great job of
putting a face right to everybody right
and making you feel like you're part of
this community whatever they've done a
great job of doing that
and as somebody you know because they
they were sort of
in second place or behind they needed to
do that and i i love that i
i love that we have faces that go along
with
with these people it's like somebody's
gone away from that completely
if i could oh i'm sorry i'm sorry we
gotta get you in here yeah
yeah shout out to the lord tim dawg you
know he's always said he's like
if you have a lot of uh you know issues
with microsoft
they are tweet away and a lot of the
times they will respond to you
and answer your questions like you know
but we we do need to get the super chats
and then we need to
take care all right yeah they're
stacking up that's all right we got
stitch with the five dollars
question how worried should sony be on a
scale of one to ten if microsoft also
announces a digital version of the
series x
speculating here uh i i don't think it
would do microsoft anything
to announce that a couple of days before
the the pre-orders go out
um i mean if if they announced it today
maybe but i i don't know my thinking is
they would have done that but again if
if if boom's rumor is to be believed
the digital version yeah yeah and we
have uh juno's 23 with the 2
super chat the tcl endorsement coming
waiting on it
then we have nintendo guru with the 10
super chat king representing that mario
in the background much love my brother
hello bad bit my son
oh oh no that's my papa that's my papa
then we have brett with the 20 super
chat cog salute
let's go rtx 30 series uh were you able
to snag one
well you were able to get he probably
didn't even probably attempt
and for what i'm hearing you happen
again for the wrong system
then we got a spotlight with the four
pound super chat oh with the five dollar
five pound super chat people sticking up
sony uh is
what people sticking up sony is what is
wrong with the industry
never be a fan of companies it stops you
from being objective be a fan of you
always absolutely yeah absolutely
because i see people in the chat like
yeah but these guys lie too
and that that's not the point they just
want your money
that's the biggest thing that annoys me
you can't criticize the company without
someone else bringing another company
you know like i said you always look at
someone silence when they can't
criticize their favor that's what i look
at y'all silent
if you sit there and say you know what
i'm a sony fan this is wrong i'm an xbox
fan
this is what we call nintendo like
nintendo y'all wow with this
limited edition you know what i'm saying
we call it out but when you're in the
chat and you're on social media and i
see y'all
and y'all never call out your favorite
i'm going to look at you sideways
that means you don't want to admit and
you have an inherent bias
and that's the problem with the gaming
community that's a blind bite
let's go ahead because he's has to leave
here real soon oh yeah all right yeah
let me finish
quick they got 14 element appeal to
three dollar super chat 1440 makes you a
better player the book of s
then we have dreams yeah 176 with the
five dollar super chat
do the corporations give the green light
when it comes to date and time of
pre-orders if so it's all on sony but
hey sony apologize three days later this
was sony's way of creating mass hysteria
that's it yeah
let's get back no but i just want to say
one thing later brother
uh to to hop on solves point and then
i'm out of here for sure
uh microsoft is is usually the trend
setter
you know when you're talking about like
they'll announce something now it's
unpopular five years later it is the
it is the standard like you know the
xbox one's original
vision yeah when we talk about game pass
you know and people discount
you know discredit it that's coming guys
whether it's a year from now two years
from now three years from now
but it's kind of cool
people think it's like 20 years away
yeah yeah it's sooner than you think
in 20 minutes messing with jim and dan's
room
tell everybody what you're doing tell
everybody where they can find you yeah
and gang listen uh
once again fantastic speaking with y'all
you're already
honestly some of the best people out
there uh
cognito i get to say this right here on
there so incredibly proud of you man
being unlocked making moves making moves
with the iron lords y'all are
growing at a rate that just blows my
mind so thank you all so much for having
me you can find me
over at big games uh where i talk about
all things game news reviews and
unboxings
that's where i have the video version of
my show the trophy room yes
playstation podcast made by the players
or the players where each and every
thursday me and my best friend kyle talk
about the latest the greatest and all
things
playstation yeah man and you can find us
on apple pod
spotify wherever you get your podcast
services and mr bad bit over on twitter
so
that's all i said all that out of the
way everybody i just want to say man
when i met him in boston uh
you know he is every bit of as an
infectious joyously
as over this uh airwaves as he
is in person he is a great person
and you were one of my highlights when
uh when i got to boston's i swear
thank you and likewise guys again keep
making the moves everybody love you
appreciate you brother thank you
all right lord gaming forte
the aftermath yeah
wow so this is why i always tell people
don't cap for companies cap for the
games that you love
because all of this stuff like this
like there's only one thing that really
truly pissed me off in this whole
situation it was the pre-orders
because i was directly in fact impacted
by it
working in retail yeah so that's the
only thing that really pissed me off
like microsoft has done such a great the
one thing people say microsoft has
pivoted messagings all over the place
which it has been
but the one thing that's always been
consistent is how they feel about
playing your games where you want to
play them at and the consistency you're
talking about it started with play
anywhere
games being on pc we have an open
ecosystem
pc is xbox xbox's pc i remember that
quote from like 2015 when phil spencer
said it
and it was like they started training
people back then
and a lot of people even people on this
pod was like man that's kind of taking
away from the ecosystem of the system
but over the course of time you get used
to it and you're like it becomes part of
like
man why am i mad that more people get a
chance to enjoy a game
that i'm enjoying and that was the whole
thing that kind of was
mystifying to me this entire 2020
going through all of last year people
are like
xbox has no games because they're
exclusive to other platforms well
why is that a problem if you enjoy the
game
just enjoy the game now we're getting to
a situation where
sony has been taking all these notes
through the course of this whole year
and they tried to pull a 2013 all over
again
they said microsoft has taken the brunt
of
all of this criticism about their
direction and where they want to go with
these games
and then sony says we're going to give
you a great showcase
but then we're going to have one more
thing at the end and we're going to tell
you all of this
bad stuff pretty much like how they
tried to say you can share games but
guess what ps4
you're paying for ps plus now the only
difference is people pay attention more
now than they paid attention then
people were excited then and it got
washed away
um in a sea of just nothingness compared
to now
everybody's super hyper focused on
everything that these companies are
doing
and when you when you cap for a company
and tell a company like oh i 100 support
what you're doing
you're you're basically telling them
that
it's okay to basically bend me over and
do anything
that you want later on it's like i don't
i don't
get that mindset that people have when
it comes to that because guess what
did microsoft sell me an ex x
no i tell i tell you all the time
it's a third-party company named bungie
that said that
their game is going to be 60 frames per
second 4k ultra realistic graphics
and that's the reason i'm buying that
system because my friends are on that
system
and i can be able to enjoy the platform
that i want does
x does is xbox my home platform
absolutely i love the xbox ecosystem
but i'm not about to just bow a need to
them just because
they're bringing a new system they got
to give me a reason to buy it
and this and this narrative that people
were spending that
oh all these games are going to be on
playstation 5 and all this other stuff
and i'm like
sony comes out and pulls the rugged from
under you
and now the situation is oh sony
their games are great so it's okay
their games have always been great so
what so
so now is it about the games or is it
about the system
and goal post moving let's just call it
goal post movie so
so to me so to me that's the biggest
hype
the hypocrisy in the whole thing i don't
i get
why sony's doing what they're doing
listen all of those games like demon
souls
i i truly believe that game's probably
only going to be ps5 for one reason
demon souls doesn't move a needle when
it comes to sales like that
it only sells like two to three million
um games
globally when it comes to the release of
those games and this game is going to
probably do the same thing
so there will probably be a nothing to
equal
yeah this one will do more but i think
this game
is going to sell well on ps5 because of
ps5 but guess what do you really want to
put
miles morales out there right on seven
eight million systems this holiday right
when you sell
they're gonna have eight million systems
yeah you won't even have eight million
systems this holiday
they sold 15 million copies of
spider-man
you you think they gonna take half that
hit going into next generation
i see the numbers that you obviously you
see those numbers right i still think
it's coming to ps4 because i don't think
they care
you have a hundred and twelve million
ps4s out there that's what i'm saying
you can sell even if you sell two to
three million
uh demon souls on a ps5 right you could
you could sell that much on a ps4 and i
think they'd be happy with that
that's the only sony console out this
year
the system's getting delayed they have
kiosks in the stores that have
xboxes xs and x's in there
that's true where is these playstations
if you've got
millions it's going to be delayed
you're hopeful hopefully you get it for
christmas i don't care
nothing and your own king and get it
preordered it says different bro
i've i've i've seen it i've seen him say
well you know
due to what's going on and right now
culver is the enemy
so due to what's going on in the world
at this moment
the plate we want to make sure the world
can enjoy our play i can see it right
now
enjoy our place
they're trying to take your money right
now so you don't give it to microsoft
i'm gonna tell you exactly the strategy
and this is what i would do
you know and you're gonna you're gonna
have a ball with this
the only reason that i'm i don't think
that's gonna happen
king is because the clearly i believe
there's a
there's going to be a huge shortage when
it comes to ps5
because of the amount that people are
able to pre-order
uh you know i i think that's we're going
to maybe
so because they said there's going to be
it's going to be just as many ps4s as
ps5s
at this point can we really believe them
because i don't think that's going to be
the case
it might be the case but just because of
the precautions
and what we're seeing going on i think
they're definitely coming out 2020
it's just they don't care how they don't
care if half the
the install base can't get a console
they're like but we're going to get this
out
you can't get something they don't have
i don't care
so the biggest thing is okay so it's
just
the timeline just just the stuff that's
come out
over the course of the last 48
week how however long this has been it's
just been crazy to think
how how far playstation can
literally pivot in that short of a time
and everything they were doing
to me it's just disappointing to know
that
people don't understand the business
side of it it's like
i can't get mad at a company for wanting
to make more money
that's why my enjoyment isn't tied to
owning a ps4
or a ps5 it's been once i saw god of war
i was
good i knew god of war was coming sooner
or later
but that just that instantly because i
remember telling you
um i remember telling you addict i was
like i don't know if i'll get the ps5
day one because i don't know god of war
probably ain't gonna go come back to one
yeah that right there made me want to go
out and buy the system day one
and guess what i'm a person that these
pre-orders man
these pre-orders so i
work at a store like i i ended up
getting one because i am a per
i am lucky enough to be in a situation
where
i got a text message from my dm saying
yo get to your store pre-orders are live
yeah but a lot of people don't have that
option it's like
we told people at my store when people
were calling
soon as sony dropped the thing said
pre-orders um are going up soon
people recall in my stores like yeah
it'll be up tomorrow they'll be up
tomorrow first thing in the morning
hundreds of people were calling my store
and then all of a sudden they go live at
six o'clock shout out to walmart for
blowing their water
yeah yeah i'm not gonna be mad at
walmart for doing it
but that that didn't happen with xbox
xbox announced their stuff almost two
weeks ago
yeah right and it still hasn't like what
they have analyzed all the all retailers
that break street date
on pre-orders they penalizing them with
cutting their shipment
yeah and they can do that when you have
all access
yeah you can do that and that's the
thing for me it's like
yeah did the the 30 or so systems that i
got did they all figured out yes did
guests be able to get the system yes but
ultimately the next day when i came to
work
i had to tell a line of 75 plus people
that they went live the day before after
we literally told them
that it wasn't going to be available
till today the fattest part before
taking out the country was when
obviously
i got the word thanks to information but
um
you know going in there and i remember
going to the gamestop and i'm making eye
contact with the store manager in the
back
and i'm like yo yeah what's good
he looked at me like oh you know you're
saying so he's like yeah
so i'm seeing people on the other line
say playstation 5
yep and i'm like yeah reserve yo
pandemonium broke out wow so many people
got off that line got to where i was at
it was like
like they just put everything down bro
30 minutes that thing was a mob
and and then the rest of them couldn't
get it so it was sad the way it happened
because so many people were true fans of
it
had no idea they were completely
blindsided by the time they even
realized
it was over you know what i'm saying so
that is really atrocious as far as this
way the situation was handled
because the core base didn't even have a
shot you know what i'm saying
but could you if you wouldn't know if
you weren't on twitter you definitely
didn't know
at all nothing and so so to me that was
the
the biggest tragedy the whole thing but
ultimately it just comes down to
sony is going to make decisions i tell i
tell everybody that
jim ryan is literally the cfo still of
sony he's just masquerading as the cs
the ceo at this point
because he's making business decisions
that's going to make the company
profitable
sony playstation is literally the number
one reason that sony still exists
at this point let's be for real so so
with with the jim ryan point right i'm
gonna
i'm gonna what i'm gonna do is kind of
consolidate one o'clock already so i'm
going to consolidate all the rest of the
the sony topics into just continuing
this one
so like you said jim ryan is still kind
of in charge in different capacities and
he's just masquerading as something else
so what do you think to the to the
points that he made afterwards when he
was questioned about
sony's potentially having uh thought
about
doing an xbox series s-type did you see
my tweet
no i did it that's right yeah oh oh so
so
so this dude comes out so didn't do
so
tweet right here let me i feel like this
is about to be messy
okay very messy all right so
jim ryan on the lower spec decision of
doing a ps5
he said based on our research it's clear
that people who buy game consoles
continue
to want to continue to play for four to
six years and even
seven they want to believe that they
bought something that is future proof
and not going to be outdated in two or
three years they want to have faith that
that
that um that the tv that they are buying
um with their current gen console
can support 4k tvs that they are
considering buying and then i
i said okay huh that might be right
about 30
of your player base because 30 of your
player base is the hardcore
but then i said i quote tweeted as i
said
if most people thought like this
statement more people would jump into
the pc ecosystem
most people don't care all they want to
do is boot up their game and play with
their friends
this is this thing it is a huge
generalization
of your entire player base and that's
exactly how i feel about
because you're basically telling me
first of all this system is this has
never been done
there has never been a base system in a
lower
system that have completely been like
devoid of each other in power
the xbox 360 that just had a smaller
hard drive
the p3 that basically just had a smaller
hard drive and it had like ss like
little
ports for like memory and stuff like
that but the core components of the
system has always been the freaking same
there has never been anything like this
so the fact that you're saying that
people um they value this and i equate
this to the whole the whole 4k like he
said 4k tv
4k tvs are definitely affordable they
are very affordable now
there are people with 300 tcls like he
says in their housing
and they happy as hell a lot of these
people out here in the next what
two months are gonna have consoles that
cost more than their tvs
they're literally that's gonna be the
thing but let me ask you this
a lot of netflix the biggest streaming
platform on this planet
nothing's bigger than it they have two
subscription services if you want to
stream
they got a basic they got a basic
service and they got a 4k
streaming service how many which one you
think would be the most do you think
that a lot of people that have four
like me 4k tvs can literally stream at
4k
but they own a basic package of freaking
netflix and ain't
taking advantage of it let's be for real
right now man this this dude
like the more that comes out of his
mouth the more agitated i get because it
makes absolutely
no sense because now you're trying to
like backtrack in real
and try to try to get some type of w
against xbox
and did you notice i i think there's
somebody else running microsoft's social
medias at this point because they're
just
they don't smoke status right you don't
hear and what happened
normally phil spencer um greenberg
all of them always come out and they
congratulate sony on their marketing
on their press conference you know nice
to see gaming at an all-time high
and all that other crazy stuff they used
to say crickets
didn't say anything about what sony had
said
all you saw was a whole bunch of googly
eyes looking at price points
a whole bunch of stuff talking about oh
spider-man miles rods going over the ps4
googly eyes memes and stuff playstation
but
microsoft put out a tweet talking about
oh we're gonna let you know exactly when
you can pre-order your xbox um your xbox
on november 22nd check your local
retailer for the
timing you know why they don't have to
be nice to them no more they already
sold them to service
yeah they're already under contract now
so we don't need to be playing nice with
you no more you're already
in pocket so that's my whole take on the
whole jim ryan thing it's like
the dude he was once the dude that told
everybody that we're we're trying to
protect the kids now he's trying to
now he's trying to tell us that the kids
can run the playhouse and they can do
whatever they want yeah remember that
remember that no chrome player because
we protected the children
you know what's funny about this whole
thing like you know what it reminds me
of when they say this is
this is how you reserve don't worry we
got you it reminds me of that this is
how you play used games thing back in
the day
yeah yeah what will we say that jim ryan
is the new millie vanilli
and what was that one thing they were
talking about like they wanted to get on
microsoft
um where they were talking about the
social media and stuff they were talking
about
how about the games and how they're
going to be um put out and stuff and
then i'm sitting there like well
playstation's doing the same exact thing
now so uh and not everyone said
well jim ryan didn't say that well y'all
talk about stuff that aaron greenberg
says all the freaking time and then
y'all want to hold phil spencer
um accountable for it doesn't that stain
thing still work when it comes to jim
ryan and everything that happens under
him
oh that was a random marketing manager
that talked about
how um you can get your pre like we'll
give you ample amount of time for your
pre-orders
uh he's still under jim ryan he's still
part of playstation
so that falls on him too and let's be
for real one day
is not heads up right one day it's not
heads up
now when microsoft gave you two weeks
that kicked his balls off before i get
up out of here about it wasn't even one
day
there was another hour 16 hours
basically okay okay
all right yeah lord king let let's let's
go enough for this captain
um let me tell you something
how do you how do you lock something
down if you have nothing
right now we we know
that and this is not far-fetched we've
known
now that it's come to light that they
have prior knowledge and they have
prior um
intentions with being
no fully deceiving
okay knowing
what they're telling you is a lie
in text verbally
and also with uh gestures
like uh so you mean to tell me that
these games can't be done
on uh anything else
look at you like how dare you
we believe in generations okay
also telling you that it was going to be
back a path let's not let's let's
let's not walk away from that
they haven't told you what playstation 4
games is going to be backwards
compatible
that issue and at the same time they
told you let's stop this talk right now
you will not be playing playstation 3
playstation 2 or playstation 1.
so for all right remastering engine
remastering
yeah hold on let me get to that the
frauds right now
for all of you frauds
they said they're doing something
way different than anybody else
let me tell you i've seen it it's going
to enhance it
it's going to demand that what they're
working on is going to blow your mind
it blew your mind all right it blew your
mind so much that
it's not coming it's never
coming all right so now this is how you
this is how you trap a fool
i'm gonna show you how you travel fool
right all right because they they showed
you
now this this listen to my logic this is
how
a liar moves all right
here we go oh there we go now i told
y'all
this playstation might not come out not
this year
and y'all like shut up king they already
went live with the pre-orders
they told you price after microsoft
they they and forte has confirmed
they are being willfully deceitful
with the digital they just they just put
that
there just to give you that that 400
dollar look and
and it's 3.99 but it's 400 but you see
the three and you correlated with only
hundred dollars like for some weird
reason yeah that one penny
the psychological thing changes
something in your head
right you see the 300 you're like oh
they're close to the uh
to the series that's in price and it's
the same exact thing
and not to mention king they short
product
produce let me let that's i'm getting
into that
for you individuals that's running
around saying it's the same exact thing
go now and look and see if the ssd
size is available on the digital
and now it's to be determined all right
check out
how you trap a fool
y'all had your money in your pocket
let's say this is your last hundred
dollars
right in your pocket you knew microsoft
told you pre-orders will go
up on the 22nd sony does they show
they give you price and then they tell
you
tomorrow tomorrow
pre-orders go up tomorrow so isn't that
we ain't giving you two weeks to get it
together
and they lied and told you in other
interviews oh you will have an advance
ahead of you and
what we're going to do our strategy is
not to ambush the customer
we want a friendly rapport it was
nothing
friendly about
so some people learn about the
pre-orders by going to ebay and say what
the hell are you talking about ten
thousand dollars well
confirmed pre-order there's no such
thing as construction
these dudes this is how you trap a fool
okay so now all the people that got
there to pre-order they got your money
right microsoft joint is on today
let's say you want to fix income
now you had the money for the
playstation and the xbox but now you put
all your money on the playstation
dropping your money on that xbox that's
the full trap you're trapped
now imagine this right imagine this your
money is already held here
they delay it
you have not seen that one playstation
yet
right
all over the street everywhere every
channel you go to every tech head on
youtube
get a mysterious package to the house
boxes you're going to stores there's
xboxes
now one playstation and they're
launching two days
away from each other supposedly
you don't see you know how they show you
the factory with them on a conveyor belt
to your playstation 4s they were going
conveyor belts they showed you boxes
someplace she was like oh
i can't wait you have not been
a box you seen the setup
for dummy now
this is plausible they got your money
they locked you in they say well
you know we have to delay it because of
the kovich situation
and uh it's disheartening but we want to
make sure that the world
can get the product so we're going to
delay it at least until november january
and uh we will have a crazy lineup
to kick not to cut you i will save this
and normally
at this point i can't even question
anybody lately
right now so he's on fire right now the
thing i will say in your defense that is
a little shady is that i've been seeing
people who
have put their pre-orders down and like
for example like ran and people cut like
with amazon
and they're getting messages like we
know you pre-ordered
but yo there's no guarantee you go get
that we're sorry
we're gonna work through it i've been
seeing messages
this is again amazon and they say
that they're gonna honor
your pre-order and your composite so the
day is released
you buddy will get your playstation 5.
now does that hurt because i'm a
four-time sucker too guys
i'm in this with you we all in this
fight together you think what's in here
bashing playstation i was the first one
to start putting my pictures up
i put my pictures up i was in i was
there i was in line bruh
there was nobody else in the store i'm a
kid
yeah it's [ __ ] i mean if
this happens i want to revolt
i want you guys see because knees is no
longer
a credible source of income from these
are no longer applicable
they're no longer applicable in this
industry
asking for elbows because you don't have
more media either
but you're kidding but look
this is okay this is the thing that i
think how microsoft is strong
on in the game forte
talked about microsoft was really good
at people not breaking the street date
microsoft has all access they become
their own distributor
when you're their own distributor and
you control the product
if somebody comes out like if you step
out of line walmart like that stuff
you won't get a red scent in these
streets
and you will have to cancel all your
pre-orders and best buy
will get your whole allotment what yes
oh you got to get this super chat
i got all the super chats but i'm gonna
skip and get to the last one that just
came in right so we got
quality gaming with the five dollar
super chat hey
sony didn't lie you fools are just
fanboying
sony quotes stating that they they will
support crossgen for a while coming next
gen
stop being emotional yes they said they
were going to support crosstalk for a
while just the other day
we got more we got quality gaming with
two dollar super chat over console
you're just fanboying
stop being emotional over console sonya
is not your girl girlfriend
you just finished listening to us saying
i thank you i thank you
i thank you for your bread thank you for
your breath
and the fact that you think that i'm
emotional over something yeah out of
your mind
but the best part about that whole thing
is
where do you fall in this whole
thing here see you like being lied to
you one of those individuals that
likes being lied to or you just woke up
obviously you just came out of the coma
yeah sony never lied because they've
been lying the whole time
he said but he said he's not doing the
same thing and so he said sony has
always supported their last gen
before they stopped making games for
them no wait
wait wait look you see that sony is not
doing the same thing as sony you're
right
he's doing something completely not
doing exactly what sony said they were
gonna do from
six seven months ago they definitely
ain't doing the same thing that sony was
doing
the franchise that's not sony anymore
he said that's a franchise why is
yeah it's no longer the same people
that's running the show
and under the old regime
i cannot wait till sean layton's book
comes out yo you know
yeah a new york times bestseller
anyway look i'll i'll finish up like i
gotta get rolling yeah what the king man
you're on fire everybody
pretty much said what they had to say
look man you know this this is the uh
the era we gotta you know hold people
accountable we gotta um you know
look at what what's being said and what
always look at the actions
that's what i say look at that don't pay
attention to the words look at the
actions and
that applies to everybody microsoft xbox
you know
that applies to just about anything in
life at this point yeah exactly look at
that
that person could be in your face oh man
i'm doing x y and z there's not a third
but you look at the track right
and at the end of the day like i said
the pre-order thing this handle we know
about you know the whole ps4 thing
honestly doesn't make business sense of
course of course
all we would have liked to know was that
from the beginning because it was a
whole base that really thought one other
thing
and um to your point so i'm like
it's it's just funny it's funny to see
how blind faith hurts people
it's just funny to be like if you're a
gamer and you're getting everything
you know what i'm saying you won't have
that emotional stock the way certain
people are and i know this thing is that
emotional stock
and they can't accept it and they're
still fighting but this but what about
with little jimmy and what about what
this one did and what about that one
just just calm down get out your
feelings
recognize what has happened to you and
correct your actions
because that is what this is a business
there's more ps4s out there and i
we get it just one transparency that's
all it is and the pre-order thing
look to king's point i hope i hope he
ain't right with this
i've been right with everything else
you've been on fire sir
they calling you a prophet they call you
all type i see barry on the back with
his hands up
you cheering victory
at the end of the day like i said i want
to see how this
is going to be handled if they're going
to have more manufacturing stock
eventually
you know what i'm saying and show me one
i'm telling
all i need now is that digital foundry
austin evan break down with it in front
of them
and they're putting it through its paces
that part right there is the only thing
i have
you can catch it watch it catch fire
other than that that's all i got good
looking for
oh yeah i got a bunch of super chats let
me get these and then i'll
get my bars off and then we'll go um so
we got
uh michael aka best size finest the five
dollar super chat
king did you see the fans through ryan
under the bus on twitter yes
and rightfully so yeah ryan ryan
then we got squirrely down with the two
dollar super chat lol king spitting some
mc hammer bars on the low
then we have jonathan b with the five
dollar super chat king has said plenty
of things in the past that we didn't
believe up front and now look at us
on the ps3
bro if they could they would i tell you
that right now
uh we got synrob with the 2 super chat
uh addicts stand up and turn for us they
want you to model
i want to see the full trucker man look
man i even
even i i even just located one of the
man
like oh my bad there we go there we go
oh
you took it off on the side so i'm gonna
put it down too
oh
brad with the fathers which that's the
biggest stance house tony did consumers
dirty with pre-orders
that just doesn't feel right oh and game
stop for the win
for the win for the waiting pursuit we
got dragon wolf with the two pound super
chat a mate has three sons
none have 4k tvs in their room yeah
there you go
three xbox series s's that's what it
that's what you get um we got quality
game oh we got that we got some we got
that one quality gaming
uh we got shansu welcome shansu to the
round
put the crush in the chat thank you so
much
yeah everybody want this playstation 5
that we give
you guys are you know it is the best
because i've seen the same reaction with
the s
xbox and you guys are definitely showing
up for that playstation i'm not joining
until they giving away a playstation
they're giving away a playstation join
all right there we have easy shock with
the two dollar super chat uh gamestop
let
gamestop let me pre-order one of each
ps5 model you got lucky
better you better better make sure that
you go in there and change the address
on that second one
it will come up in the system at some
point um then we have gamer by choice
with the five dollar super chat
if you look at politics why should
gaming be different people are okay with
getting lied to
and say i'm okay with that
all right so these are the last ones
that i got anything else jump up in the
chat
no that's it that's it it's all right so
right so let me round this out
um with my bars off i'm gonna tell y'all
right now
like jim ryan came out and they they
said
we believe in generations
and he does it's just starting four
years later than he said it was
that's all it is at the end of the day
this this happens when they make
promises to their base that they
know full well in their heart they have
no intention of keeping
because that is not business that is not
business like i said before the people
that run this business
do not care about your console war they
do not care about your wall
garden they don't care about you having
something to hold over this other
console manufacturer
they don't care about that the almighty
dollar is
the bottom line and when you have
someone like jim ryan in charge
you have him there for one reason to
make sure that the flow of money
continues to increase on the playstation
side right
you guys seem to forget that just a few
years ago at the beginning of this
console generation
had playstation been a failure the
entire
entirety of sony might have been in the
bushes because the playstation
what was propping it up and at this
point it's still the same way
right sony's tvs have gotten better
right but
none of none of their other consumer
electronics
moves the needle the way playstation
does so playstation by default
has to be its biggest money maker
they're going to do the most to adjust
their way of doing business with
playstation in order to make the most
amount of money
it's only natural and like i said before
microsoft has always been the first ones
to pivot when something when a paradigm
shift is coming
and they've always been the ones to take
it on the chin and everybody telling
them they're wrong
and here we are yet again and this time
playstation rather
than sticking to a false narrative for
as long as they can they're like no
man we can't stick to the narrative the
money's on the table right tell me tell
me this
if would you make more money selling
a brand new playstation game day and
date on three platforms with playstation
5 playstation 4 and pc
or waiting the six months even six
months
to put it on pc or to say you're going
to put it on ps4 as well right
dude the zeitgeist for selling something
is at the moment of a
point of original sale right you will
have
that's when everybody's talking about it
that's when everybody's interested six
months later you'll get your sales don't
question right
because we've seen what happens years
later with games on on steam and
and whatnot right people excited for
horizon people are excited for the
master chief collection
all of that stuff sells but not the same
way as if you put it on all these
platforms in one shot right this isn't
something i'm saying that sony's going
to do outright because
to appease their base they're not
immediately going to do
the the the harshest 180 ever and put
everything day and date on multiple
platforms
right their own platforms meaning
playstation 4 pc whatever the case may
be
but it's going to happen and it's going
to gradually go to that and you guys got
to let go of it and what
i say you guys it's the people the
ponies the ponies who stood on this
square
and this was the argument point it's
always been a stupid arguing point
because
if you really care for playstation as
the platform
if you really care about playstation
games
this is the right move this is
absolutely 100 the right move
are we gonna get these next-gen
showcases that can't be done anywhere
else
not for quite some time right deal with
it deal with it i've been saying this
forever scalability in
in in developing games has been
something that's been going on for the
for since the beginning of gaming right
right right
beginning of gaming this has been the
truth right if you want to talk about
the the design
argument whatever listen if you want
innovative design day in and day out
play nothing but indie games you're
going to get innovative design day in
day out you're going to get somebody
that's broke with no money with a
fantastic idea
that's going to make a game on a nickel
and you'll be excited and happy with
that
understand that that the big three when
it comes to
innovating they innovate based on what
the new bells and whistles of the
hardware brings
right right based on hardware
innovations
you're not going to see a lot of design
innovation in games
that they bring to the table because
there's too much at stake with these
games
most of these games are franchises most
of these games are multi-million
million dollar sellers they're not going
to take the risk of changing the formula
to appease some the this this design
argument that is not it it's not
mutually exclusive to the money argument
and jim ryan understands that the money
argument and the design argument and the
and and and the franchise argument is
all hand in hand
right so he's giving you what you want
and you're gonna have to accept that
it's not gonna be the standout thing
it's gonna be great
but it's gonna be on multiple platforms
and this is where the sony guys really
have to understand look
and i and this is where i know a lot of
people have pivoted to at the end of the
day some of these games are still great
yes pivot you can pivot to that all you
want
it but it is the truth yeah there's
nothing to be mad at here
if there's one thing true that jim ryan
said is that nobody should be mad at
this
what you call it allison looked amazing
right we stepped there we were so wild
about it we didn't
watch the game and say look how they
scaled that back there you know
selfishly gaming is inherently selfish
it is selfishly
i did like the idea of what jim ryan
initially tried to sell because you had
two philosophy differences
right you had microsoft saying you know
we're not leaving you behind and then
they pivoting the opposite way and
saying no
we're leaving people behind and you're
going to get a playstation 5 because we
want to push the technology to further
know if you bought all this trouble and
spending for a console
there's a part of me that didn't want to
see how that would have worked for them
because it seemed like he was on his
square so
that was the part that hurt me
personally because i'm like damn fam
like you you
made me believe it's like i was i was in
defeat you know
what ssd could leverage the tech and i
would
[ __ ] full blown nothing you know i was
in i i i
was right there with him
it's a philosophy difference at the end
of the day yes the games are going to
show
what they show but i do agree with you
you saw ultimately you're right
when this is a business there's so many
playstation 4's that's out there in that
wild
yeah it'll be stupid to launch or the
system that has been limited supply that
you'll have
all that base to not put those games on
that platform yeah exactly and that to
me and just to just to finish it
at the end of the day unfortunately has
been saying this all day love the games
love the games and you'll never be
disappointed you may be disappointed
with a game high comes out whatever but
you'll never be disappointed by all the
other vitriol that happens around
it the games are what's most important
always have been
always will be the box once it comes out
once the boxes are in our hands
the conversation around that the power
all that stuff that'll be over with it's
going to come down to what it's always
going down to
it's going to be the games and i think
both platform holders big platform
holders
are are ready to do show us amazing
things
but just don't be fooled by marketing
speak
and buy into that because you're going
to be disappointed and you're going to
be standing on a square it's going to
make you look dumb in the long term
so that's that um let me read these last
two super chats and then
we got quality give me again with the 5
super chat i never said
i never said they never lied they do
support their last gen you can't prove
me wrong on that until you got
nothing here's a tip what i'm listening
but we're all saying
he made a statement the main thing is
that
when microsoft said something and they
saw that they got a negative reaction to
it
it only did what sony does and is they
made something to capitalize on that
negative reaction
same thing they do with digital games
exactly and the same and the thing is
that what they did
what they said in that specific reaction
was a lie
that is that's the case i don't care
that they're going to ps4 fantastic it
is a wonderful thing
support your the console that you have
nearly 150 million of in the wild
support
just don't lie about it and and that's
there's no way to get around that they
lied about that that's just straight up
they like i can't wait for the last of
us to remix
for seventy dollars 79.99 baby
uh ultimate edition 79.99 oh yeah it's
the ultimate edition with the spider-man
okay so check it out you're gonna get
the 79.99 is the new price for the
ultimate edition
it's called now the ultimate edition so
79.99 for the last of us two
and goes to sashima shout out you know i
think that um
the one thing i'm looking forward to
seeing finally is what what
this playstation collection that they
kind of coming out oh they just i just
retweeted that right so it's like
they have a list of all the games that's
in there but if you look at that list
it's a great list don't get me wrong
playstation 4 games on your playstation
5. but there's one thing that's missing
on that list
stop i want my knees please what what am
i getting
what i'm getting i'm getting these games
on my ps5
what am i getting that's making these
games better on my ps5
oh nothing oh they said all they said
that it would it would speed up select
games
yeah but but where microsoft but and
that's the thing and where microsoft
takes all of those same games if it was
on their platform they're saying hey
guess what
free of charge we're giving you higher
resolution higher higher frame rates
ai ray tracy yeah like like
battlefield 1 was on that list and
battlefield 1 was the first game that
had ray tracing in it but
i'm getting battlefield 1 on the new
system but you're not even giving me the
benefits of what the new system have
now granted granted i love that you're
giving me these games it's it's a great
way to induce people
they give you anything you better pony
up
people absolutely king's absolutely
right we you got a pony up for that
playstation plus because guess what that
fake number that they put out there like
what last year where they said 94
million people are on playstation plus
or playstation memberships guess what
most of the games that people play now
are free to play games and that's the
one benefit that you have on playstation
you don't have to pay for playstation
online to have it
but guess what they count all of those
playstations and scripting numbers
as people that are on playstation
membership yeah so
well that's about the change though the
paywall is about to go up uh
you will not have access to any of those
games trust and believe
jim dance moves ryan is changing the
paradigm baby and you are going to
pay like you wait so make sure you got
your bucks up
cause jim
just a reminder that gaming forte is
getting destroyed in fantasy football
today yeah
because he mad that i destroyed him
three games in a row plus the
championship game last year but that's
okay we only had week
right then we got that we have we have
gotham guy with the 5
super chat gaming 14 will gamestop
stores be open at 8 a.m for store
pre-orders
great show as usual as always guys thank
you sarah uh
so it's based in region so um
we're only going to talk about america
here because you know we don't know all
the other regions when it comes to their
time zones like greenwich mean time and
stuff like that
find that out by just googling so um
east coast
est is 11 a.m central time
is 10 a.m mountain is nine
and west coast is eight eight a.m so
they're literally they're not doing the
whole like basically they're saying
god's time is est and we gonna fall in
line in all the different regions when
it comes to that so just be at your
store depending on what region you are
and what time zone
and they should the only times on that
matter is
esp hey y'all already get the benefits
of playing games early
and staying up late y'all might as well
have to wake up early
and get y'all games too almost every
other scenario
being uh you know in the eastern coast
hurts us like you know people be playing
at night
my kids ain't going to school that day
people will be playing at 9 00 p.m
you're gonna have a refreshing that's
what you're gonna do what i'm gonna do
is i'm gonna say
i'm gonna yell out because they're in
class i'm gonna yell out
what what the hell happened to the
internet and then they're all gonna
start it off at the same time
we're gonna go down again
we can't even call what happened this is
the best because they
see daddy said it's cool so they went
daddy that you
and they all gonna go to burger king
right now
it's our home school that's right that's
right
y'all all are gonna get beautiful burger
king burgers whatever you like
order what you like cause daddy is gonna
get he's using you right now for your
name
because you're like you're gonna strike
the credit card fine
time let's continue this super chat
if you are pre-ordering that game stop
don't walk like listen as much as you
probably want to walk in there with your
system now and
i probably shouldn't say this but just
keep the system
at least until the week before the
systems come out trade it in them yeah
the promotion that's going on in
trade-ins is going all the way to
november 30th so if you do it today or
if you do it on
the day before the systems come out
you'll still get the same promotion when
it comes but
if you got those switch games get rid of
them before the end of the month oh yeah
yes max you see this
i'm gonna show it here this right here
this is why you go physical
because these games right here are
paying for my xbox
what is this 10 switch games this is
literally enough money
to buy my xbox because guess what
nintendo shout out to you for never
dropping your prices
yeah um and your games whole value so
this is why you go physical for some
stuff because you never know
when you don't have to spend your own
money it's only for you because you work
in the store and you getting that real
like we going to start with those same
10 games no no no it's the same brother
everybody get that king maybe
i have proposed a new segment once a
month or something you have a featured
fan join as a guest for like 15 minutes
give the spotlight to people in the chat
who always killing it
i nominate jonathan b to go
you know what i think that's something
that can definitely be done
we're working on playing with the
community so we will be doing live
streams
with the community so in that way every
member and every patreon member can have
a time to shine with us
while we're playing games what we love
instead of just talking about games
we can actually play i can actually beat
the hell out of you in some fighting
games let's do it
we have we have bounty boom with the
five hours which i just got up sorry i
missed the show long
night can't wait to listen to it while i
go to work absolutely brother not it oh
no
good thing we have elemental peel with
the five dollar super chat
if you've seen the five heart beats
then we have jb golden with the five
dollar super chat ultimate edition of
miles
is 69.99 okay so not 79.99 that comes
okay
i thought it was the switch through
spiderman also that ps plus collection
is only on ps5
sorry ps4 owners yeah why would it be on
player four
it's it hold it up here it's fine all
right that's it on super chat so
gentlemen
that brings us to the end of our show
thank you lord cog the boss for coming
for chiming in
you know after after coercing me to to
host the show
absolutely i held it down yeah you gotta
help me down while i'm away man but yeah
salute to y'all
holding it down giving us that premium
premium knowledge
what'd you say we got another super chat
oh god you get it we got we got
microwave bed size finest with the five
dollar super chat forte i have a
question
what is the trade in value for the xbox
one x scorpio edition that's the one i
have i believe it's 200
brothers brother all x's and all the
plate what pros are two hundred dollars
now let's get out of here i like i said
at the top of the show i'm not as
creative as cognito so i don't have a
new
poll it's all good we'll leave it too
i gotta pull back oh we have the wise
old gamer as he always does pulling up
the rear the wild game with the finals
at pause i bought six playstation 5's
and put my name on the receipt on
twitter
which one of you ps boys lacking i got
to oh
wow
he knew he was gonna do that right now i
had to hit him in the dm so take
down that picture you got your phone
number in there
and you got it you got to scratch that
out so yeah yeah
get big shout out to mr bad bit for
coming through i know he's a very busy
man
he double booked so he had to get up out
of here but big shout out much love to
mr bad bit playstation
nation's finest and of course our
brother gave me forte
tell us what you're up to brother nah
man this um
it's great being here in the realm with
you guys man cog was like man i gotta
get fourteen
crazy if i don't yeah but um look man
you guys are
you guys kill it every week man it's
it's amazing being here with you guys i
truly
appreciate what you guys do that's why
i'm always going to be a supporter but
when it comes to myself uh gave me forte
everywhere youtube and twitter man
um check me out over there got a video
going live on tuesday morning because
guess what tuesday morning is when
destiny goes live into game pass
so if you're thinking about jumping in
it's going to be a video live to tell
you exactly what you need to do to get
started before the new dlc comes out so
check that video out on tuesday
um outside of that man shout out to
everybody that subscribed to the channel
man we hit 2 000 subs over the course of
the last week
we're making we're making these moves
man and um it's all thanks to you guys
if it wasn't for you guys the videos
wouldn't be as good shout out to addict
for helping me out
with the growth on the channel too and
my man slow-mo backslap
my partner in crime he's probably in the
chat to me me me right now as i say this
but um check us out every uh tuesday
eight at nine p.m dps podcast damage per
second we talk about
all of the crazy things that's going on
it's probably going to be a little hot
and heated because we haven't talked
about
this whole sony thing on there yet and
he has some very very big takes on
what's going on
and then finally uh baseball radio
podcast every wednesday
my man enrique friend of the realm one
of the best people that's out there
make sure you support that man on his
channel too because we
if you want the most unbiased con you
know other than this show
that's the show you want to be on
because we just talk about games and
that's the one thing that i care about
the most
but outside of that man it's been a
great show shout out to you be safe out
there cod
we'd love to see you when you get back
man thank you brother look out lord
addict
where can the people find you you can
follow me on twitter at lord addicts iop
you can find me on uh youtube at gaming
addict you can find me
not lying like sony
but you know it's definitely been a
great show you know we had
one point we had like 520 definitely
want to appreciate everyone from coming
through
uh when sovereign ends it i'll play back
his uh his
his promo again people who missed it and
we'll see we'll see you next week you
know
you definitely want to see that you
definitely want to see that lord king
where can the five people find you first
and foremost i would like to uh
definitely give a shout out to mr bad
bit and mr gaming forte
forte um there was a discrepancy
with uh your jersey don't worry i'm
going to
fix all of whatever you understand what
i'm talking about
yeah um so it was because of the
companies one company folded
and uh don't worry i got you because i'm
going back to the store anyway to go get
some stuff for me so while i was there i
was shopping for me and i'm going to be
shopping for you as well sir
so i'd like to receive a package in the
mail from me
and this holiday season that will
definitely
uh jiggify your situation all right
um you've really been a great supporter
and
um i understand so trust me i got you uh
this was a great day um give a shout out
to cog because
you know a lot of times he he flies here
and there
uh and more so during this pandemic uh
i'm a little bit more nervous
with the the flighting and the
procedures and what's going on because i
haven't taken a flight
uh anywhere during this time so for him
to be this courageous to do whatever
he's doing
and to get home safely this is all i
wish for
uh guys check us out on a new kls
box right here i got a couple of boxes
that's over there uh go
check out that last word we're low
incognito andy bontes had a real uh
returning uh guest he's definitely funny
definitely let me show the death quickly
check out
um and uh listen give it up to attic
for putting on his trucking suit and
give it up to saul holding down the
floor
and putting his video he's got his
video up and it's it's a beautiful video
man y'all got to check that out
the one thing i do want to bring before
we leave you know uh you know
shout out to all the writers at lords of
gaming.net you guys ever want to go over
there and have
see quality work you know i'll put the
the link in the chat
and i'm sure you see all these these
the uh this these shirts the the banner
back there behind
king you can always go to the website
and get that from there too and uh you
know we'll see you next week
no you're not going to get that at the
website
cognito had one too i thought it was all
in there probably special order
good to see my brothers holding down
call you know what i'm saying saw what
the duties on the mic you know
say hold it down without some stuff i
want to see more of that sir more of
your face out there
i don't know what you're talking about
but yeah i like that promo we got that
little latino community
lit right there so i'm happy we have a
super chat though
uh yeah so we have uh sin vendetta with
the five dollar super chat i'm a scorpio
myself so i'm keeping my score edition
to the end of time
and we have jd gamer with the five
dollar super chat hate that i missed the
show i know it was on fire i'll catch it
on replay no doubt my brother
oh yeah that's for me you know me i'm
lord sovereign you know where you can
find me
going to work i'm about to have lunch
with my wife and then
heading out to do what i do uh but big
shout out to bad bit
14 coming in joining us obviously my
brother's obviously cognito
for having faith in me to sort of man
the ship while he's not here
this is a week baby vacation this is
terrifying i will let you know that this
is
terrifying to to have to sort of man up
man a show and sort of direct
conversation
is one of the best and he is what's
not an easy thing to do and i hate doing
it
what's funny is is i was going to do it
and call you just like soft could do
it's like okay
you know he was quick to be like yogurt
i was impressed okay it's all good
behavior thank you for taste
i really feel sorry for the fans that
were standing on that square and backing
these dudes
you know that really believed that stuff
and and now you're getting a cold splash
of water in your face
um but also think about what i said with
that delay man
[Music]
i'm glad it's back together let's just
start talking about the games
and back to this club and all of that
absolutely absolutely
uh guys everybody good luck we're
getting your consoles on tuesday good
luck
with uh the re-up of playstation
consoles hopefully if you didn't get a
pre-order you can get it now
well the xboxes will come out this year
and with that we'll say goodbye peace
see you next week
and watch this
hi this is lord sovereign from the iron
lord podcast
as you guys may recall a few months back
king david otw announced an amazing
giveaway for the xbox series x
well i'm proud to announce that the iron
lords podcast will once again be giving
away another console
at the end of this year and that console
will be a playstation
5. you heard correctly so
how do you get in on this amazing
giveaway let me explain
if you're already a member of the realm
you're good to go if you support us
either on patreon
or youtube you already have a ballot to
win this amazing console and if you
support us
on both platforms you have two ballots
to win this amazing console
as you also have two ballots to win an
xbox series x
so if you're not a member of the realm
what are you waiting for head on over to
patreon.com
go to the ironlord's podcast patreon
page become a member of the realm
to get your chance to win a playstation
5.
you can also join us on youtube iron
lord podcast
become a member of the realm and you
will also have a ballot to win
a playstation 5 console and if you want
to support us on both
platforms you'll have two ballots for
each system
to win either a playstation 5 console or
of course as king david said
and xbox series x this is an amazing
opportunity
that the iron lord podcasts are so happy
to bring to our community because you
guys give so much back to us
so again if you're not a member of the
realm yet what are you waiting for
go out join the realm on either patreon
or youtube and until next time i'll see
you at the round table